recording to the right
thing
now if you selected record to the cloud
that should be fine and then I started
the stream on YouTube as well okay
that's what I couldn't see before thank
you okay is my voice loud enough yes yes
okay thank you all right as chair of the
house Ways and Means Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result at
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a revenue work
session please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listening contemporarily to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporar during the meeting through
the zoom electronic meeting platform and
the public has access to contemporar
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice of this meeting
complies with house rules RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS
l.n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Christoper and Brad
Greenland please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by a roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call of attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no
law representative Bernstein break the
role thank you representative major uh
good morning everyone Representative
Patrick
abami a sound check too is this any
better I can hear you any better okay
you're of a lower volume than everyone
else though all right I I I tried
changing a setting anyway I'm here on
stratum uh at home uh my wife's in the
house uh representative Mary
Griffin representative
Griffin representative Jordan
oy here home Al uh with my wife
someplace in the
house representative
obber representative
obber representative Fred
ducet good morning here in Salem
alone good morning uh your clerk Alan
burin is here in Nottingham New
Hampshire in my home office by myself
representative Robert Elliott here with
my wife in the house
somewhere representative John
Janan I'm here in Salem with uh my wife
and daughter somewhere in the house
representative hero
Nunes good morning I'm here and my
better half is in the
house representative Timothy Baxter
thank you representative I'm here in my
house alone representative Walter
spillsbury here in my home in charl town
my wife son or elsewhere in the house
representative Paul tutor Aon Northwood
and the Celler wife and grandkids are
upstairs representative Susan
Aly here in Lebanon and I am alone
representative Richard Ames I'm here in
Jeffrey and I'm alone in my home office
representative Thomas Southworth I'm
here alone in my house in do
representative Dennis
Malloy morning I am in in my home in
Greenland and my spouse is in the house
temporarily now
tell representative Thomas
shamberg Tom shamberg here in wilmet and
my wife Joanna is in the house
representative Edith Tucker I'm here
alone in
Randolph representative Jenny
garlo I'm here alone in my kitchen with
my husband
outside
representative Tom
lofman representative
lofman representative Amanda gorg good
morning I am by myself in my home
office representative Mary hackin
Phillips good morning I am home alone in
Hanover with my two dogs representative
James Murphy good morning I'm here in
Hanover uh in my house with my wife and
daughter elsewhere in house
representative Norman major good morning
here in my home in plasto and my wife is
in the
house great job everybody nobody had
their mute button inadvertently ESS any
there's 21 of us here three of us are
not here back to you
nor would you just check on
representative Griffin again
representative Mary Griffin are you in
the
house I'm not seeing her let's check the
attendees there's no phone numbers but I
do see Jerry String's name good morning
Stringham okay uh Norm before we get
started please yes oh one little thing
um the uh pet dog of Aaron and uh oh I
forgot her name Meg Megan is expecting a
son oh W ma good shattering brother a
brother is it going to be named
snowball I have no idea it was just an
announcement I saw in one of my uh
postings today but other than that might
as well start with a happy note I
think June June okay um today starts the
work on Revenue
estimating and we're going to start off
before Chris starts with Chris Shay
who's our legislative budget assistant
budget director and he'll go through the
worksheets but this is
the we're not going to make special
estimates today all we're going to do is
really go through the
process we're going to bring in each of
the agencies head they will
explain again the go through the history
of the
revenues and what they estimate the
revenues are going to end up this on
this year
fy21 and their best estimate at this
point in time on FY 22 and
23 and
direct Chris Shay yours thank you R
major and members of the committee um
represent major had asked me to set up
your Revenue estimating work sheets and
to schedule today and tomorrow to be a
time when you can go over the worksheets
and have agencies available to answer
any questions you might have as you're
looking at these revenues and and
thinking about how you want to do your
estimates so he wanted me to start with
um just showing you what the documents
are and kind of how they're set up um if
you I sent an email on Friday to
everybody with all the documents um you
should have received three PDFs one was
an agenda one was a PDF of the worksheet
and one was a PDF of um the highway fund
estimates and then an Excel worksheet
that is the um estimating worksheet that
you can play in and and add and subtract
numbers and make adjustments as you
would like to do so what I'm going to do
is share my screen and just kind of walk
you through the estimating worksheet
just so you can understand what I did
there
and
so are you seeing uh D the tab Dr high
low
estimate yes okay it's a little
small all right let's see if I can it's
a full size on my screen so I don't know
what I can do and while he's doing that
I encourage members of the committee to
uh don't hesitate to ask
questions interrupt them that's this is
a learning process for you and for all
of
us
okay chis if you zoom in yeah
I'm now is that much
larger
yes all right so to start with what I
did is I took um Dr came to you last uh
last week and presented um what they
what their potential estimates are for
the different Revenue sources that you
would be looking at um collected by
their agency which is typically the
business taxes meals and rooms tobacco
tax um interest in dividends
communication Services tax utility tax
the um and the real estate transfer tax
one of the interesting things you have
going on this year with your revenues on
a cash basis is that $30 million of
Revenue that shows up on a cash basis
going to be backed out at the end of the
year because it was money that was due
in F fiscal year 20 not 21 so on this
page here and I'll just go to row four
or row nine which is four here um you'll
see that for 21 you have a low of
$799 do8 for the business taxes that
removes the $18.3 million that was the
um cash that's going to be back going
back to fiscal year 20 and so that's how
I grew based on the percentages provided
by Dr the revenues for 22 and
23 so this is just a one page for you to
look at with all these um uh the Dr
Revenue sources and you can see what
percentage it was growing by so the the
low number
7998 in fiscal year 22 was growing by 1%
so 111% of your previous year and then
the high for fiscal 22 was growing by 3%
over the high of um fiscal year 21 and
that same pattern is followed throughout
this table here okay let me stop there
yep when the Dr comes in and they
799.99
point8 and what makes up that
number why isn't it lower or or higher
ask those questions
24.2 why did you pick this and what's
the reason behind
it but but I just ask Chris on you said
that you took on the anomalies out of on
799 ripson Vol you went mute
did you take them out of column d as
well yes yeah
yeah and that's the right thing to do
because uh those anomalies were there in
your
projected growth or decline in coming
years you'd have the wrong base to start
with so now I have a question you just
referred to those as anomalies I thought
they were just payments that were
received because of that July 15th
federal tax date that people got
confused with so is it an anomaly or
just in the wrong
year it's in the wrong year it's in the
wrong
year but the Dr has been calling them
anomalies and and I think that that's
the um nomenclature that's been used
since they've identified that um so it's
not just ER using that now so it's a
it's an anomalous receivable that was do
in fiscal 20 they ended up in fiscal 21
and then I think uh commissioner stpp
had explained to you that there's that
60-day window after the close of the
fiscal year where there's a adjustments
made to your revenues and and that's
when they determin that that Revenue
should have been or would have been
collected in fiscal year 20 if the
federal government hadn't extended the
um filing date to July 15th for your
federal
taxes so barring any changes like that
you would have collected that Revenue in
fiscal year 20 and not seen it in 21 so
what we're trying to do is smooth out
the estimates for you here so you don't
um overestimate what potentially what
you might be seeing in future
years I don't know if that helps or
hurts but you that's the explanation CH
is that 18 just a part of the 30 million
anomalous that was attributable to July
and August yeah yeah so if if you look
at um the Dr
presentation um from last week on page
56 I believe of their
presentation there's a table that shows
the the various um amounts attributable
for that anomalous revenue for each of
the B uh Revenue sources
yeah and then that's a taken out for
each one of those go to page 57 of that
same pres their same presentation you'll
see where they um they've already
accounted for those anomalies or that
receivable Revenue by removing it and
these numbers should all tie to that
thank
you if they don't let me
know oh just I also resent the documents
this morning just before this meeting to
you um in case people didn't see it on
Friday when I sent them so it's and I'm
using the um house Ways and Means group
email to send the documents they're also
available on our website um in the PDFs
I didn't put the Excel
up so that's so that's how you get the
uh the taxes are the revenues that Dr is
going to be speaking to that's how I
come up with those numbers and then I
bring them into the next tab which is
the GF ETF which is general fund
education trust fund
worksheet and you see here the business
taxes um for the 21 you should see the
agency low and high should tie to the
number that's in the table on the
previous tab and the same with 22 and
23 on the worksheet we also provide you
fiscal year 2020 we give you the
official plan so what was anticipated at
the time you the revenue estimates were
done and then what the caffer um showed
for actual Revenue coming in
understanding that the official plan is
on a cash basis the cafer is on a a
modified acral basis so they're slightly
different but the caffer number it
becomes your official Revenue number you
know that's the number everybody will
speak to that the state collected X
dollars but everything you do on row
nine and um below are typically on a
cash
basis for other agencies that provided
you estimates such as liquor um
commission I took their number so for
fiscal year
2021 they had a an estimate of 129
million and because they didn't provide
a range I just put that both as the high
and the
low and so you will see that with most
agencies outside of Dr did not provide a
range
um so you'll just see the same number in
the in the low and and high
estimate and then that goes through each
of your unrestricted general fund
education trust fund revenues on row
four of the worksheet you're going to
see gen gen and ETF or just gen or ETF
and that just tells you that um that
Revenue Source either goes totally to
the general fund totally to the
education trust fund or a split in some
manner between the two
funds but as you do your estimate you
typically will do them as a as a total
and then after um I will try to do an
approximate split or an estimated split
between the education trust fund and the
general
fund so the just this same pattern
repeats for the
highway so there's a worksheet you've
got the fiscal year 20 then you got the
21 22 23 estimates if there's a range um
it shows and there is in the highway
fund and it's only in the motor vehicle
estimates and that's because there was a
different estimates provided by judicial
branch and the um Department of Safety
on what they thought would come in for
those Revenue related to what judicial
branch collects actually and there's a
one-page sheet that I had also provided
that kind of gives you a little bit more
detail so you can see some of the split
less detail than what safety provided
you in their page but more detail than
this page provides you and then the last
place you're going to do estimates is on
the um fishing game on restricted
revenue and again they they provided a
single estimate for each year so there's
no higher low and as I stated for each
of these um Revenue sources I've tried
to schedule on the agenda to have the
agencies available to you as you're
discussing them so this morning Dr is
Avail um as soon as I stop speaking um
so if there's any questions that you
have excuse me related to any of this
information here on this page where you
see the uh the ranges that I put based
on their
information um you know they're happy to
help you understand why they did what
they did but this is really a time for
you to you know I think to talk um with
each other and kind of understand you
know why the revenues are what they are
at 11:30 um Health and Human Services
will come into the call and they'll be
available to talk about recoveries if
there's any questions related to that
and then this afternoon at one o'clock
we have the highway fund um and I've got
the department of safety judicial branch
and Department of Transportation all I'm
going to be on the call at one o'clock
and then once you're done with Highway
fund discussion judicial branch will
discuss its um its
Revenue that you see um the court fines
and fees on this page here which is a
column
I so that's all that's all I have at
this point um once you start making
estimates you know as the committee
starts to talk about and say you know we
believe in fiscal year 21 we should end
the year and the business taxes at 800
million and then in 22 it's going to be
820 million and in 23 it's going to be
850 million I'll populate the sale sales
for the highway uh house Ways and Means
estimates and um provide you a new
worksheet each time you work so that you
can see what you've discussed
again this is just a worksheet it's not
the official document that will um be
voted on uh by the the committee may
vote say y we agree to these estimates
and from there um typically what's
happened in the past is that put
together a house resolution with your
Revenue estimates that you bring to the
full body um and then earlier in the in
the call I think R garlo was asking um
you know what do you do after you
basically do your initial estimates and
and rep some major indicated and as in
past years uh the committee has
typically come back in May and June to
revisit it it's Revenue estimates um
April and excuse me March and April are
two large months of Revenue particularly
with the business and IND taxes um
insurance comes in then so really those
are we consider those kind of make or
break months and then June is a is a
large estimating month
so that's all I really have at the
moment unless there's any questions for
me Chris can you go to page six and
R oh oh in the highway fund no no in the
fund the total
yes
so so that's that is just your that's
the total all the revenue estimates that
you've made they're they're not split
out by in this in this worksheet I
haven't split them out by Highway excuse
me by education trust fund or general
fund this is just the total general fund
Revenue unrestricted Revenue that um
will then be used by finance committee
to to appropriate in places where you
see General funds are needed so on your
Excel worksheet yep in communication tax
of a million dollarss that will
automatically populate a change in
column R yes yep yeah so so the only the
only calculation that's occurring is in
column R that's going to Total
everything across from
um a through Q will be totaled across
the bottom and and you'll get a total
for your your um your estimates and
you're able to
see what is the estimate for FY 22 look
like for FY 21 and the actual for
fy20
yep that'll tell you if the total
revenues are going down or going up or
much and with the Excel worksheet you'll
that major could I just add something
that some people don't understand we
have to put a single number into the
sheets uh for each year in the end
because we have to give a single number
for the total uh in the end to the
finance committee it goes into the
budget as a single number in the
end
Y and if I might rep up major the
committee is working on or focused on
unrestricted re
revenues these are the general fund um
education trust fund revenues go into
the education trust fund and are used
for um adequacy payments or adequate
education payments as well as um this
last year they were used for
um um special ed and tuition and
transportation and building Aid that's
the first time this this last budget was
the first time that the education trust
fund was used for that in the past it's
been the general fund um and that
was decided during the last legislative
session but anyways so so you're there's
other revenues that go into the budget
that are already restricted or already
have a purpose so your budget your
revenues are your Appropriations are
typically over a bium you know thir 13.2
billion dollar that was for this um last
b b we're in right now um so you had
revenues and federal dollars that were
helping support that you don't
necessarily
estimate um so I just wanted to to
mention that because you know you may be
thinking about you know you're in
Department of Employment uh
environmental services and you're
thinking about wetlands and and the
programs there how are they being funded
well they have dedicated funds and they
come to the uh finance committee with an
a suggested budget and if the
legislature votes on that that's how
much money is appropriate ated from
their dedicated fund that they can spend
now there are funds that are continually
appropriated um that the legislature has
asked agencies to um spend as they need
to but those are only allowed through
statute right when you look at the
budget process and look at House Bill
one house bill one will have budget for
each of the agencies and there'll be a
total appropriation and then it will say
revenues will be so much from The
General one so much from
the so much from whatever other funds
there
are and will deal primarily with the
general
fund correct representative major I have
a question
yes um getting back to this question of
a single number or a range
um the for for sure in the end it's a
single number that goes into the budget
and uh that um in the in the end Ways
and Means has to come down in a single
number but um what I'm wondering about
is earlier on we're early in the process
and if it becomes evidence that this
committee sees a significant range of
possibility and is
uncertain it seems to me that it would
be helpful to find to know that and um
to express our our estimate of that
early juncture as a uh as a range and
also an historical thing I'm I may be
misremembering but uh in the last
session when we were confronted with so
much
uncertainty um didn't we uh send forward
AR
range
Reon major could I answer that sure we
we agreed um to send ranges to as the
update to the revenues okay on in in I
was it the fall or the late or June it
was in June repi yeah in June and we
sent H our estimate of how bad or how
how decent the revenues could get it was
pretty Grim in those days uh so that was
that's the first time I think that we've
ever done that and I hope it will be
able to be the last but we might want to
do that um later
on for instance when a representative
major starts arguing with the senate
about the revenue estimat which is not a
fun thing to do uh that he if he has a
range in front of
him he can feel a little bit more
comfortable maybe about going up to
where they want to
go our first battle is is to get the
budget through the house and I'm in
constant communication with Ken wer
who's chairman of
finance and he and I will be
talking almost
daily on where things are going relative
revenues they they want to know and we
want to share our information with them
so they understand too this is a working
progress
so and we need to continue doing that
process Mr
chairman yes represent Elliot uh on line
28 am I reading that correctly is that
yep almost three bill
you any other questions um before we go
agenda Norm can you hear me yes uh just
on repres Aly was that the when we did
the range is uh did that become a house
resolution or that was just
informational that we we gave to
everybody it was a vers of HR on the
house resolution for for the estimates
but as you know the those HRS go back on
the table and they die at the end of the
year right right I can't remember if we
can look them up in the in the history
or
not or if they are removed from the
system okay I just want major if I might
yes okay yeah you can search the house
resolution just as you would search a
bill in the um search function on the
website on the general court website um
and you did it was house resolution I
believe 16 that was your um provided the
ranges this Summer that you brought to
your um your body and and voted on or
and then um tabled them and as repon Al
me said at the end of the session
anything that was left on the table uh
dies and goes away so it starts with a
fresh slate with this new um
session
yeah and and the official
estimates will be part of when you vote
the budget either in house bill one
or that another
one so over the period from February
through June we may come out with a
number of different Revenue
estimates and whether in ranges or in
single numbers but nothing counts counts
until the final budget is passed and
numbers so that's why we'll continue
working on these until we do get a
budget
CL any other questions
comments all right then
uh it's 9:33 we'll go to the revenues
collected by the Department of Revenue
Administration here to talk of us on
that is Melissa Rollins senior financial
analyst from the Department of Revenue
and Devin rodri financial analyst from
the
Department good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
Melissa Rollins Department of Revenue
and with me is Devin Rodrick senior
financial analyst for the Department can
you hear me okay yes and I think Chris
has his hand up before I start go ahead
Chris I just wanted um to make sure that
the committee understood that the
agencies were invited to more respond to
the questions you might have um I they
weren't instructed to do another
presentation though I think um if
they're just talking about what they
provided last week most agencies can do
that but I just wanted to make sure the
committee understood that my thought was
you were going to be discussing the
revenues with your with each other and
rely on the agencies um for any
questions that you might have
but I just I just want to make sure that
that that was heard and because some
agencies might be surprised when when
they get on the call and you asked them
to
present but I will um alert them that
you may ask them to kind of review what
they provided to the committee last
week
okay all right Melissa and Devin it's
yours yes thank you Chris for um
clarifying that I don't have an official
presentation to present um I was just
going to wait for you to sort of take
your cue on what youd like from us
however you did you did State um a few
minutes ago that you um kind of wanted
us to explain how we got to our high and
low ranges so we're happy to do that if
that works for you Mr chair yes
absolutely okay then with that Q I'll um
I'll start with business taxes and then
we can pause after that and see if
there's any questions um so as Chris
stated I don't know if it'd be helpful
for Chris to have his screen shared for
yes so you do want me to share my screen
yes okay because they're going to go
through
them
one
moment can you guys see the screen
can okay so if you're ready I'll get
started um so for business taxes on the
799.99 um I'll start with fiscal year 21
and then we can ask questions and then
we can chat about fiscal year 22 and 23
if that
works so for fiscal year 21 these
estimates were provided prior to um
January 15th I think we we had just
finished the 15th but we didn't have all
the revenues in from the 15th as it was
a holiday um so these numbers have
increased slightly however the way we
got to our
which we've we've chatted about this in
other estimates is for business tax it's
a little bit different that we've looked
at each of the different voucher types
so for the new members on the committee
the voucher types are estimate payments
which are quarterly estimate payments
which are there's a couple of things to
talk about for estimate payments one
they're the most recent and active
payment that will receive because they
can be paid on the the quarter that just
ended so it's more upto-date information
however taxpayers can also o pay these
estimates based on prior year tax return
so they're not 100% accurate and two
they're probably one of the most Vol
volatile payments that we receive as
they are just a paper form with no
information coming in they are an
estimate and they can result in either
too much or too little taxes paid but
again it does give us some some inside
information as to how business taxes are
potentially performing we also have
returns and extension returns and
extension payments um these are payments
that are filed when the return is due
for calendar years that's March and
April uh these payments return payments
obviously are TR up the payment that was
short based on their estimate payments
and then extension payments are similar
to an estimate as they are just an
estimate of what the payment the final
payment should be it does not come in
with a return the return is due seven
months later and it can result in
a refund when that return is filed seven
months later and then we have tax notice
payments which are essentially bills
that were sent out to taxpayers who
underpaid their tax
liability and lastly we have refunds
which are just essentially overpayments
of
taxes where they asked for the funds
back so when we did our fiscal year 21
estimate payments for the remaining year
um we looked at those different voucher
types and based on what we had seen from
March estimate payments through current
for the low we adjusted our estimates
down
-3% compared to Prior year and returns
and extensions were down negative 18%
from prior year the negative
18% is equivalent to what we saw back in
the last recession even though we know
these are different there were some
similarities in payments were flowing in
and then we made some adjustments to
account for the economic
condition so that's our low range that
low range with the anomalous receivable
gets us to about 2% ahead of
plan and then looking at the high range
we did the same sort of exercise where
we looked at the different voucher types
to sort of adjust that because they're
reflecting different activity um during
the year and we had that where estimates
were flat and then returns and
extensions um were a decrease of 9% so
we sort of cut that 18% in half and
that's because what we're looking at
currently um coming in with the
anomalous receivable removed were about
177% ahead of plan however we still have
a good chunk of Revenue to come in for
um the business taxes and the returns
that are due in March and April those
are the returns s that are fully
affected um by the covid pandemic and
we're not sure at this point based on
estimates in the increase in Revenue if
those estimates are flowing in based on
prior year Revenue so again taxpayers
can make estimates based on their prior
year tax liability as long as they pay
100% of it so if it's based on that and
then they're going to True up those
payments when their returns are filed
meaning they will have refund requests
in March and April um and those returns
and extension payments will be down or
if they're going to
um flow in as is with just a slight
decrease so that's where our ranges are
coming in to be 2% to 6% ahead of plan
for the low and high happy to answer any
questions for fiscal year 21 estimates
or 20 yeah estimates yeah I have a
question
repr yeah so Melissa um we're what are
we we're just starting February and U uh
much of the activity I think that uh
businesses will be paying taxes
on um in the next several months has
already occurred but some of it has not
and my question goes
to what
uh to what degree is the revenue that is
still to be still going to come
in um dependent on changes in
circumstances that we don't know right
now that could occur between now and the
end of June so suppose some major
development occurs uh that uh I won't
even try to characterize that uh affects
business Outlook in some way
um to what extent given that a lot of
the uh Revenue that we're going to get
is based on things that have already
happened might that change uh affect
what we
receive so that's a good question
representative ases um off the top of my
head I can't think of anything that may
come up that will drastically change
what we've seen already
um my thoughts would be that taxpayers
are at this point now that we have
completed the year are sort of looking
through their their business records and
sort of seeing how they've they've ended
up in the the the year for the year um I
think anecdotally like I said we've
heard that estimates had been
made based on prior years activity which
would not reflect the current covid
situation um and then as we're entering
now what we also have for March and a
April April and June um for estimates
would reflect current activity so I
think some of the current activity uh
that hasn't happened yet would be if
there is or as that second round of PPP
money comes out um that that could
potentially affect the first and second
quarter estimate payments um by how much
I think we're unsure at this point as
really hasn't gone out yet off the top
of my head that's the only thing that I
can think of that would affect the
current Financial environment that we um
that may affect payments because as of
right now for the returns and extensions
for calendar year filers their activity
is basically wrapped up right
yeah
Melissa that I always kind of worry
about is the credit carry forward and
due to the
pandemic what do you think the effect on
the credit carry for will
be U after March and April results come
in I know that it's been growing every
year I think it's up to
about
quarter of a million dollars um $250
million so so if you could say a few
words on this sure so first off for the
new the new committee members I'll
explain what a credit carryover is so a
credit carryover is when a taxpayer pays
more than their liability and it's an
overpayment so with that overpayment
they can elect to take those funds in
two ways they can either ask for a
refund of that money on file or they can
request a have those excess funds
unfiled carry forward to the next year
so that carry forward amount also known
as a credit carryover is the money
that's available for taxpayers to use on
the next return or to continue to carry
forward on each return so representative
Majors absolutely correct the funds that
have been carried forward keep growing I
do believe they're around a quarter of a
million dollars I don't have the exact
amount in front of me
um um in
the a quar of a billion sorry about that
yes you're right quar of a billion
dollars um I for those funds so it's
hard to predict with this just because
again we haven't seen a pandemic before
so it's hard to see what taxpayers would
be there could be a potential that these
taxpayers could utilize more of those
funds on file so if they come into a
situation where their return is due in
March and April and they owe more funds
than what they had paid in their
estimate payments they now can utilize
those extra funds on file more than they
would in a typical year which then would
reduce our returns and extension
payments because they wouldn't need to
pay they would just sort of take the
money on file that has already been paid
to the department so I think it is a
possibility I think with our reduction
of 18% for returns and extensions on the
low end and the reduction of 9% for
returns and extensions on the high end I
think does take into
account uh some usage of the credit
carryovers however I always want to note
with credit carryovers that although
that number is rather large we do look
at that closely and um a lot of the the
the bulk of the that money is used up
every year it's sort of a wash Rin
repeat where taxpayers utilize that
credit carryover on file for their first
and second quarter estimate payments and
then they pay third and fourth quarter
estimate payments they have extra money
and they carry it forward and they
continue to use that um over and over
again so the full extent of the
liability is never you know $250 million
that thank you welcome any further
questions at this point Norm It's
Pat Melissa yeah um I I can't tell if
people hear me because my my machine is
not the microphone isn't working that
well but speak louder I'm trying I'm
trying so uh this is different than
anything we've faced in all the years
I've done this um we've come out of
recessions and things like that uh but
usually fundamentals are bad when you're
coming out of a recession that that
created the recession fundamentals were
good going into covid and so the real
issue I think before all of us is you
know when is the vaccine gonna uh take
hold uh is co going to diminish it's a
guessing game as to when we think
normality will return I'm sure every
business is having the same conversation
about their estimates but again I think
it's a little different than coming out
of a recession and that the fundamentals
are so good we heard from the economists
that there's pent up demand we heard
from the economists that there's a lot
of cash on the sidelines waiting to be
spent but nowhere to spend it uh so I it
I I it's not an easy job for you or for
us I think to especially the business
taxes to uh to estimate what what the
companies are thinking right now it's
more of a comment but uh how much of
your conversation was around covid I can
imagine it was quite a
bit yeah great Point representative
abrami and I can hear you just fine just
so you know um a lot a lot to be honest
with you um very hard to predict taxes
during this time as um other St states
are facing this as well we've never seen
anything like this before it came on
really fast uh as um representative I
believe Aly alluded to earlier when we
were ending June we really thought we
were going to see this huge tank in
business taxes and we were going to take
massive losses and then um come to find
out we were we were wrong with that that
you know the federal government um
definitely helped out with some stimulus
packages as did the state of sure and it
seemed to help support this and we also
saw this really fast Trend in change in
behavior of where people just shifted so
they shifted from you know going into
stores to going online and then we saw
people being home so being home in this
pandemic we there was a lot of activity
at box stores and different home
improvement stores to you know fix up
their homes which then resulted in a
change into the real estate transfer tax
so
it it's been a guessing game to be
honest with you uh every single month we
just are are unsure on how this is going
to perform because we have nothing
historically to compare it to as you
said it's not like a typical recession
it's sort of like a reverse Nike swoop
you know we we were at one point we
dropped way down then we're coming back
up so it definitely has been a challenge
to predict I think that's where our 22
and 23 numbers come in where you were
asking about the pend up demand and the
vaccine with business taxes there's sort
of that year lag right as the returns in
um returns and extensions are filed a
year later based on the prior Year's
activity um we may see that decrease in
those returns and extensions because of
that that pent up demand meaning on the
other side of it that people maybe
haven't been out gone out and spent as
much money as they typically would but
once things open up and the vaccine
comes we may see more of a growth and um
smaller businesses can might you know
perform better than they they did during
the um the last
year we have three hands rais
representative
bur thank you Mr chair uh good morning
Melissa and thanks for taking my
question with with regard to assistance
from the federal
government if those loans are forgiven
that income becomes taxable to New
Hampshire businesses can you explain to
me how you factored that into your
estimates sure I don't first off I want
to say you are correct with the PPP
money that um if those loans are
forgiven we would see that um in the
business Enterprise tax if they spent it
on wages so we didn't apply a particular
number to um to our estimates however we
did adjust them up further than what we
had anticipated seeing of what the the
loss would be because we know and we saw
actually the estimates not drop as far
as we had anticipated so we made an
assumption that these estimates are
padded with um some of the federal
stimulus programs as well as the state
programs um that helped support these
businesses in times where they were um
they may have been struggling and we
would have seen a further loss in
estimate payments um so I think we
initially thought we'd see a 12 to 15%
loss in estimate payments we then reduce
that to 10% and then reduced it to 3%
and that sort of factors in um those
those funds that were helping out
businesses very good thank you you're
welcome repres
n thank you very much Mr chairman and
and thank you for coming in to speak
with us and help us through this I'm one
of the new guys so um I I believe that
you sort of touched on an answer that I
was going to for represent bursting um I
wanted to talk about the the business
defaults that happened within the state
during uh the pandemic um I know in our
our little town here we had uh we had 11
vacant stores in our little town at one
time uh I know that some of those have
come back but um we know that most of
our business taxes are collected from
our larger uh corporations um is there
going to be uh too much of of a hit on
us from the the amount of small to
medium businesses that did actually have
doors yeah great question and welcome to
the Ways and Means Committee um yeah so
right now looking at the way the
business tax is performed the large
driver of these payments is really the
cor the large corporations they're
really pushing this forward and the
smaller businesses which we are
typically the
proprietorships uh those businesses not
um they they make up a much smaller
portion of the revenue but they have
definitely been taking a hit they are
not their returns and extension payments
as well as estimate payments have been
down um pretty consistently every month
where the corporate the corporate
payments and the larger taxpayers have
been seeing an increase so I do think
they are affected and I'm I hope that
they make it out and I hope that they do
well
we don't have a specific breakdown that
analyzes those smaller businesses
compared to the business we sort of look
at it as an overall whole um because the
the bulk of the business is carried by
the larger businesses so we do look at
them however they're not a huge factor
in the revenue
estimates thank you very
much great uh represent Aly followed by
representative
Southwest thank you Mr chairman and we
seem to be heading in interesting
directions I have something on top of
Representative nunes's great comment on
it's how much work would it be to I've
got two actually uh to
separate uh those who pay only bet from
those who pay uh bet and
BPT on to for instance on the on the
chart that that we get each time that
shows us the
monthly uh returns
estimates uh extensions Etc um over the
last 10 years um wouldn't have to be
like that but if just for this last year
on the those businesses that we have
never done this the businesses that are
only paying bet versus the others
because it does seem like we do a lot of
talking about how people are going to
spend a lot more money on after things
start to calm down whenever that's going
to be um but we don't really know what's
happening to those small
businesses I think I understand number
of them F folded without even doing a
bankruptcy so
um it would that be a lot of work no no
and actually representative elme I do
have those numbers for tax year 18 which
was our last completed tax year as you
know it takes a couple of years a tax
year so for tax year um
18 40
41% um of the business tax filers filed
only bet
43.4% filed both bet and BPT
returns and 15 or 16 rounding
16% filed um just BPT
returns Melissa can you send that to um
to me and I'll send it to the committee
we sure
can if I could follow up on that how do
you get to file just a
BPT so a BP PT would potentially be um
proprietorships that's what's coming to
mind off the top of my head so you have
somebody who um has their own business
they have their gross receipts exceed
the
50,000 and then um they're not meeting
the BET threshold so remember the BET
threshold is less than the BPT threshold
so they hit the BP threshold with their
gross receipts they're required to file
based on the greater than 50,000 but
could potentially have less than the I'm
going off the top of my head I think
it's like
222,000 for um bet they would file the
BPT
only that's really interesting uh that
includes an awful lot of proprietorships
that the person is retiring and they
have to sell their interest in what what
they've been doing uh what they
owned and it ends up in BPT because it's
a lot of money in one year
uh known about that one for a while but
uh in terms of the ones that are filing
bet do we bet only do we have a way of
of looking at this past year on what
their their returns and estimates and
Etc have
been we would we would for tax year 18
not for tax year 19 yet as those of the
returns that are going to be filed in
March and April for calendar year filers
and then throughout the next year and a
half of fisal year filers but could we
incomplete we could take a look at
what's been filed so
far okay thank
you thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question I had almost word for word the
same question as representative Nunes
but as a followup um even though most of
the revenue comes from the larger
businesses because of this particular
crisis it just seems we really should be
tracking what's happening to our small
businesses just to think about the
future of New Hampshire because the
small businesses really are very
important even if they don't have a big
impact on Revenue so maybe not for this
meeting but it does seem longterm term
we really should try to find out who's
you okay well no more questions at this
point you can continue
Melissa okay so I'll move on to fiscal
year 22 and 23 so fiscal year 22 and 23
we did a growth range of 1% to 3% for 22
and then for 23 we did a growth range
for six uh 4% to
6% for fiscal year 22 that information
will still have people will still be
coming out of the covid pandemic
situation so we didn't think the growth
would be as large as 23 we're hopefully
fingers crossed we're um back to some
good some good growth um GDP is expected
to be 4.3% for the calendar year and
calendar year 2021 and we know that
calendar year will be part of fiscal
year 22 and then will be um more felt in
fiscal year 23 so we tempered the growth
some in 22 and then picked up the growth
in
23 happy to answer any questions on 22
taxes br
you did say that again uh for 22 and 23
the GDP estimates that you used and and
where you got those
from so the GDP is expected to be 4.3%
that was reported out of
Kiplinger um and that was for calendar
year
2021 so we tempered that growth in 2022
because that calendar year 2021 will be
felt over a couple of f years with the
bulk being in
2023 uh as we have hopefully um full
recovery if not more recover exceeded
recovery once the pandemic is has slowed
and we're we're kind of back to normal
so that was for calendar year uh which
calendar year was Kipling or saying
2021 okay over 2020 did you use any
other uh future you know any other GDP
estimates from any of the uh the gurus
for 22 and 23 so for the 4.3 I should
have explained Kiplinger takes a look at
multiple gdps um GDP growth rates and
provides an average so the one to three
and the four to six was scooping in
um sort of all of the gdps that they
report on which was quite a few of them
I understand that uh but how about for
future years day was there a crystal
ball for uh GDP growth in future years
there was not at that at this time I'm
not sure as of um this was as of a
couple weeks
ago okay I just wanted to make sure I
you okay uh repr
we
you're muted Susan that was I thought I
thought I'd unmuted you had I was um
putting Norm's hand I mean uh Patrick's
hand down in it oh sorry sh you're in
progress of doing something
sorry okay on can can you look at the
Kiplinger again to see if they put out
more um more estimates for later I but
what I'm looking at is uh the larger
corporations have been doing well as far
as I can tell one because they were
really good at pivoting to something
that the pandemic
needed and could charge a lot more money
for it because everybody's in
crisis and the second one is that
they've still got all of those corporate
tax cuts from the federal uh uh tax uh
reform in 17 end of
17 so um is there any idea that you've
heard in DC that they might be reversing
those corporate tax cuts or are they
operating under the presumption that
that this is not a good time to reverse
anybody's tax
Goods uh that's a good question I
haven't heard anything yet
um our predictions are based on what is
sort of happening today and hasn't
adjusted if something does change it
doesn't take into effect if um there is
um if the Biden tax plan changes
anything um it just is as of what's
going on today but we we definitely keep
a close eye on that and we'll make any
adjustments if something were to change
just give it a little more
time yeah the other thing that that
comes to mind at this point is the
variants for the covid which are um
making a lot of the medical personnel
very nervous um that there may be
mutations that mean that they have to
develop new vaccines and set us all back
do we do were these Kiplinger estimates
all before the variant problem came up
um I would say potentially um they were
done two weeks ago when we created the
revenue estimates for your range um so I
can't answer that but I definitely will
look into it that's great because I
remember trying to look up estimates
several years on the on the web and um a
lot most of what I was getting was up to
11 months old I I don't know what
Kiplinger
uses I'd like to start hearing some
questions from the people new to the
happen you you'll learn a lot from the
questions that those that have been on
the committee but I'm sure that those
that haven't been uh we have questions
representative spillsbury
yes thank you very much for the
encouragement chairman
major we heard uh in testimony last week
that the
PPP raises a question of debt
forgiveness debt forgiveness is normally
taxable income but I believe the cares
act Exempted uh that on the federal
level so we have a potential situation
where PPP debt forgiven is
at the state level um but on the other
hand I suppose that the qualifi
qualifying criteria for PPP uh and for
forgiveness was that you have to
demonstrate you actually expended it on
keep keeping people employed and certain
specific business expenses so perhaps
it's a wash somebody was expressing
concern that there could be an
unanticipated extra tax hit from this
see
to Me Maybe that's not true and I wonder
if it's something you've considered does
it represent a a neutral or a potential
increase in tax
income sure great question I think on my
end you cut out just a little bit here
and there so I'm going to answer it to
what I think I heard but if I miss a
section please feel free to let me know
um so yeah there were some changes for
the
PPP for the um Federal level where they
have an exclusion um and an inclusion
where they exclude it from the gross
income um but then they have an
inclusion for the D deductibility of the
PPP however we're not a Conformity state
so we do not conform or we do static
Conformity meaning we do not conform to
the most recent um Car Act tax law
changes so that change um that the
federal government did made for the PPP
does not currently affect New Hampshire
so we are
still um we would still be getting the
tax on the business Enterprise tax if it
was spent on wages which it seems like
it would be as that was um one of the
requirements for the loan forgiveness
program we would still be getting those
taxes for that and our estimates for the
business tax ranges have included um
those funds in there and like I said as
of right now nothing has changed for the
taxability of the PPP for the State of
New Hampshire so our estimates wouldn't
be adjusted um based on what the federal
government changes have been did I
question represent spells I think you
did answer it for the most part yes you
um you answered for the most part but I
guess I'm the ACT actual event of forg
ability by and large has not occurred
yet
right uh that's a good question um I'm
not sure if that calculation has
occurred yet but it will occur by the
filed okay interesting
variable see that one more time
please I I think it's an interesting
variable that obviously wasn't
anticipated last
is okay representa
n thank you Mr chairman I hope I don't
embarrass myself with this question but
this is going to be a learning process
for me um there's nothing to embarrass
you there a learning process for
everybody uh thank you sir um I'd like
to ask the question about um last bym we
put in uh into statute some triggers
that would raise the BET BPT rates if uh
uh revenues fell below a certain point
um has any of that set in place and or
is that going to be set in place and the
second half of that question is um if
there are changes in bills coming
through to that statute that may be
implemented what type of proposed effect
are we going to look at
okay do that any of that make sense I
yeah sure it's a it's a great question
um so for the rate changes you are
correct the trigger was not met so
because the trigger was not met the REM
the tax rates remain the same as they
were um so there's no
impact being made to the business taxes
because again the trigger was not met so
it just the rate just continues as it
has been um
and ask for future tax law changes when
doing the revenue estimates we do the
estimates based on current law so if
there are changes for instance hb10 that
we spoke to um I can't remember it was
early in their week or last week um if
that is changed those will be added onto
a surplus statement and those fiscal
impacts would be adjusted for fiscal
year 22 and 23 based on um based on the
fiscal impact that we provided
that was the answer I was looking for
welcome representative Murphy Oh Thank
you Mr chairman U more in thank you for
reaching out to us who are new to the
committee but one is an observation and
another is maybe a more specific
question uh following up on
representative aly's you know concerns
about when these uh GDP predictions were
made I would probably
bet that they were made well before the
more recent CDC and Dr fouchi concerns
regarding the variants have come out uh
my concern is clearly that these
variants are going to be a game Cher
that we may see in March in the
springtime sometime um and unless there
is a significant shift in production of
vaccine booster shots and even
Therapeutics um I I worry about the the
first year of the bium and any Revenue
you know um projections upward um and
even if we have a significant amount of
vaccines out there the behavior changes
are going to take a while to happen so
that's more of an observation which in
my mind speaks to a more conservative
Approach at least in the first half of
the
banum my more specific question I guess
is um
the in the market-based sourcing and
single sales Factor transitions that we
are making uh how is that affecting the
highs and lows in the estimates that we
see uh from the Dr estimates on um
revenues uh do they have any impact at
all is that a naive question or uh I
just didn't know if these two trans this
transition that we're going through as
well uh has any significant or how does
it have an impact on the these um
estimates these ranges thank
you so those are some some great
questions um yeah any anything from here
on out that changes is going to be
challenging because obviously when we do
our Revenue estimates it's with the
information that we have as of when we
do those informations so if these
variants do become a a key part and do
affect consumer spending um and
businesses then it will adjust the
revenue estimates so that's why we build
in the range to make sure we have a
lowend and a high end to sort of say
where do you think this will fall um and
obviously these are just our opinions so
if you don't feel that they have
adjusted enough as the committee you
guys have the right to go lower than
what we have or higher than what we have
and for your second question for the
market base sourcing and the single
sales um they're really hard to take
into account because market-based Source
sourcing we don't have an estimated
impact of what that's going to look like
yet that is going to hit in fiscal year
22 but we have not provided a fiscal
impact so I would say our ranges are
accounting just for some growth but not
necessarily anything tied to or
attributable to market-based sourcing
and for single sales we won't see that
until fiscal year 23 if it's not
postponed um by the legislation that has
been put forth and again single sales is
hard to do um a fiscal impact on as
there's a lot of volatility there on
which way it swings year to year um so
fiscal year 23 is what we anticipate the
growth to be the four to six% but it
does not tie directly to uh single sales
thank you and as a a quick followup I
was very happy to hear when
representative Gario asked
representative chairman maor
you know the process going forward
because if there are significant changes
over the next couple months with regard
to the treatment in vaccinations for
covid we'll at least have a chance to
re-review once again uh in June so
that's
hopeful okay representor brahney and
then I have to step away for about two
minutes I'll be right
back okay um thank you um I just want to
clarify the the triggers uh uh unless
you had a right but I just wanted there
the second half of the trigger that
wasn't mentioned there really were two
triggers we had our estimated
revenues and the compromise was if those
revenues fell below a certain percentage
that we would roll back the taxes to the
prior years rates that trigger wasn't
hit but there was also a trigger that
the same percentage going the other way
it revenues had to exceed that
percentage for the for the tax continued
tax reductions to happen that that that
trigger uh was not hit so uh so the
first one was hit it uh but it it wasn't
both weren't hit okay so what that meant
was that all of the future tax cuts
stopped that's why there's House Bill 10
House Bill 10 is going to uh ca for
continuation of those those tax cuts
going forward so I just wanted to
clarify that thank you
just to make another comment on that uh
Patrick um or representative ofy to be
formal um the uh I think think there may
be confusion about the
ongoing as to whether there's an ongoing
trigger there's not right it's history
now the the trigger was not met and
going forward it's uh part of our past
but not part of our future I think
that's that's for sure uh
right no you asking me uh represent ases
yeah no it's it's done right yeah I just
wanted to I'm not sure that some of the
new people really understand that I
wanted to be that's why I brought this
up and that that's history now uh
basically what happened uh when when the
revenues were finally calculated for
last year was that we we froze at at a
rate and stopped any future tax cuts
that uh that were going to happen and
that's why it required House Bill 10 if
we want to continue with those tax CS we
had planned house house bill 10 has to
be passed that's where we're at right
now thank
you represent Al after that we can go on
to the
yeah I just wanted to close this
particular piece with we knew in June on
that we were not going to meet the
trigger there was maybe a quarter of a
percent chance that something weird
would happen and the CER would say that
June okay um Melissa you can
continue on the on the meals and Rental
tax sure thanks moving on to the meals
and rentals tax we have a low of
294.50 million and a high of
3125 million as you know the meals and
rentals tax has been the hardest hit um
by covid out of all of the
taxes our our low um is continuing with
a
25% loss compared to taxes for February
March and April and then slowly coming
out of that loss um for May and June
toga 19% and then negative um 177% which
is reflective of May and June and
September and October of the prior year
so our low is taking a deeper loss and
saying we're coming out of it more
slowly and then looking at our high it's
more optimistic saying that February
will be a 25% loss and then we SL slowly
come out of it through March April May
and June with March being a 10% loss
compared to Prior year I mean compared
to plan and then April May and June
being a 5% loss um compared to plan
January ended just for um some
informational purposes January ended
atga
-30% uh below plan and January is for
December
activity happy to answer any questions
rentals this is the one that's taken
biggest hit yes I have one uh Mr
chairman ra your hand sorry speaking
John representative janigian yes
represent um so the um Melissa that when
you just said 30% January's 30% % below
plan um is that so it's even worse below
I well compared to January of last year
how much is it down or is that what you
mean it's down
30% so compared to last it's 30% below
plan plan had some growth built in so
compared to last year December activity
um it was down
welcome
uh any further questions on the meals
and
rooms wow oh I have my hand up Norm
Pat doesn't doesn't show up on my screen
sorry May went down so um I'm just this
random thought here maybe maybe we
should reach out to the Restaurant
Association to give us an idea of how
many restaurants they think uh that will
not survive all of
this uh I think that'll give us a pretty
good idea given that most of this tax is
restaurants and not not
hotels um I'm willing to do that if you
to
fine I think that'll give us just a
gauge of you know the recovery rate you
know the recovery rate may be lower than
we think because a lot of them just a
lot of the restaurant didn't didn't
survive thank you we can call in
somebody that
represents the restant
association at our next
represent
gamalo thank you chairman um I was just
wondering where Patrick got that
information that most of our revenue
losses just from the restaurants it
seems like
the hotel industry isn't doing well at
all so do we need to ask them as well do
you think we have both sets of opinions
and
figures I agree with you the model why
all I met all I met was that 80% of 80%
of the total revenue was from
restaurants actually I agree hotels are
hurt as well Big Time totally car rental
places I can give you some more
information on that if you if you'd
like so for the the month for the
December activity hotels were down
39.7% which was a 2% um increase in what
they were or excuse me 2% decrease from
what they were down the prior month in
November they're definitely taking a
larger hit than the food um food or
restaurants is down
18.6% and they also gained um a
percentage Point compared to the prior
month so both taxes in December versus
November did a little bit better than
they did in the prior months I do want
to note when you look at these different
categories we've talked about this um a
fair amount in our other
presentations that full service hotels
are really taking the biggest hit so the
brick and mortar hotels that the bigger
businesses they were down 45.9 9% but
when you look at
airbnbs um you look at you know online
platforms people are staying more at
those and those actually the activity
was up 13.2% so they're ahead of Prior
year where the brick and mortar hotels
were down and then looking at
food again just this shift and Trend I
think of where people feel feel
comfortable or safe full service
restaurants were down 27%
um compared to last December but fast
food exceeded last December and was up
3.2% so those are just some of the
shifts and trends that we're seeing um
where people are making some different
choices versus going out to eat and
sitting down in a restaurant it seems
like they're feeling more safe going
through a drive-thru or staying at maybe
a room rental or a a full house versus
staying at a a hotel could you send us
this the latest
information there more
sure
do represent YY followed by represent
Aly while we're talking about uh uh the
rooms and meals
industry one of the things I've noticed
in our area is several of the uh
restaurants the small restaurants have
decided to take the month of February
off not because they're not selling
meals but because they just they can't
afford to stay open with the
restrictions that are in place and I'd
like to know from the restaurant
[Music]
well okay we can have a representative
from the restaurant and the hotel
industry come in and we can ask them
that
question
represent
Aly yes I think that probably restaurant
and lodging is the one that would be
keeping the statistics and that that's
what Patrick was talking about but
following up on representative oery
there are a lot of different ways that
these the restaurants and I I guess
small hotels have been maybe have been
closing they some of them that I know
personally have just they've just walked
away they've decided okay I'm TI tired
of trying to do a restaurant and without
declaring bankruptcy or anything they've
just gone and on their on the restaurant
and Lodging Association and anybody else
probably is only going to have a general
idea of what how many of those
businesses have quit you'll recall that
there's a lot of
turnover uh turning in the restaurant
business anyway on they I I can't
remember exact what the numbers are but
something like 30% that get started die
within a year or
50% um and then somebody else tries it
or they try it somewhere else and so
it's going to be really difficult to
track but maybe if if we asked
restaurant and lodging to make their own
categories of who they knew would closed
and who they knew was still open and
then everything in between or something
like that that we might get the best
data we
can
okay uh represent J
again yes thank you Mr chairman um I was
just thinking just more of a comment it
would be interesting when we get someone
from the Restaurant Association to come
in one of the questions that would be
interesting is I mean we've been talking
about how people's habits might have
changed and they're not going to full
service restaurants however how much of
that is habits or or not habits but just
what people feel safe and how much of it
is
regulation um that might be something
that the restaurant industry could could
help us with because if regulation is
causing a lot of the downside we might
want to look at uh not that we are going
to address that but we can but that that
potentially just a comment thank you
okay representative hackin Phillips
yes uh thank you Mr chair representative
jiki and just exactly pinpointed my my
concern was that consumer psychosis and
behavior may not be trailing the actual
um ability for restaurants and hotels to
reopen if if people are not feeling
comfortable even after vaccination or
you know if the continued variants
become worse of for the covid strains I
think that consumers may be trailing um
for quite some time demand may not pick
up for a longer period of time than we
anticipate even though the regulations
you know that the government you know
state of emergency or
um you know the certain types of covid
protocols may be relaxed consumers may
not match that you know uh appetite for
going back to sit down dinners and long
weekend stays so I think that that
consumer Behavior would be such an
important piece for us to consider in
terms of what how quickly we believe
these numbers will rebound I'm not even
sure fiscal year 20 22's um anticipation
of a 8% increase at the low is um going
reality it's the same feeling people
have about flying who have always
flown even as things change I don't
think you're going to get people to fly
like they have been till five six years
out okay all right uh I don't see
represent Aly do you have your hands up
yeah yes I I had just one followup for
restaurant lodging and I think also Dr
on if we could on it won't solve these
problems of the covid in particular but
if we could look at how much how long it
took for the restaurants and hotels to
come out of the Great
Recession before they they got back to
Prior prior taxes or tax or earnings on
that that might give us some kind of
idea of that side of the
[Music]
problem
okay and we can bring that up when we
discuss those revenues
uh let's go into the tobacco
tax okay moving on to tobacco tax we
243.166 occurred June 1st um our
estimates for the low would be remaining
at 18% each month ahead of plan for the
rest of the year which is um a trend
that we've been seeing however we also
have been seeing some stock up months so
the low doesn't include stock up months
it's just a straight 18% for the year
and then our High um includes those
stock up months but at the highest month
that we saw so when I say stock up
months um if you looked at the revenues
over the last um six or seven months
we've seen this trend of two months of
around 18% with the third month being a
much higher percent of either somewhere
between 30 and 53% increase so September
was a 30% increase over plan and then
December was 53% increase over plan with
the remaining months hovering around
18% so our high is sort of continuing
that Trend except the high being one of
the highest months that we saw in
December and the low being a continued
months and then for our growth for 22
and 23 we have a negative 3% loss to 0%
and a Nega 4% loss to negative 1% once
we hit fiscal year 22 we will sort of be
normalized compared to Prior year
because we will have the full impact of
the um Massachusetts flavor band in
effect and we feel that it will start to
go back to our normal Trends um of
around 0 to 3% loss year-over year um
with fiscal year 23 being a little bit
deeper um losses people continue to uh
quit smoking happy to answer any
questions one comment and that is if
Massachusetts decides to sell menthol
cigarettes
again that - 3% and uh
fy22 could possibly put out a minus 6 or
more that's a very good point
representative
major
normally you would go see year toe use
of
tobacco constantly decreases maybe on
the average of 3% and I see that you're
low you took that
tax say none we can go into the
interest or you see you've already done
23 so we'll go to interest and dividends
tax yep so for interest and dividends
123.6mi
so our low is 4% um 4% each month below
plan bringing us to um a 7% ahead of
plan at the end of the fiscal year I
want to note with interest in dividends
tax um a couple of things one 75% of the
Revenue comes in the second half of the
fiscal year this is very different than
the other taxes um we just saw the last
fourth quarter estimate payment come in
so we have information on that um which
adjusted are high so when we did this
presentation again it was before we had
that fourth quarter estimate payment um
127.85
35.5 um that high of
135.5 is putting us to uh 10% ahead of
plan for the rest of the months uh which
is an average of the estimate months
that we have received so far it's around
11% and we thought it's not outside the
realm this tax has been performing ahead
of plan even though at at that point
we'd only received 25% of the revenue
that it could continue so we wanted to
123.6mi % and FY
22 yeah you'd y that that would change
your 22 number also change would also
change representative major I have a
question representative Ames um okay
ra represent and Then followed by
represent
AES uh thank you Mr chairman just real
quick from Melissa this 10% uh increase
in estimates is that in any way in
relation to uh what may or may not be
coming in uh with the
PPP loans being
taxed so interest in dividends um won't
be affected by the PPP
loans thank you m
Ames yeah uh first uh it's sort of
two-part I'll just say say what I'm
wondering about uh first is whether you
have a breakdown between interest
dividends and
distributions and the second observation
I guess is that uh my sense is that U
dividends and
distributions are trending high and that
interest is not so um and that uh that
Trend that high level for dividends and
distributions is uh is particularly
sensitive I think in the future to uh uh
changes in the economy that may or may
not happen and so I wonder if uh in
looking
forward you've um what you've done about
those uncertainties how you've
considered
them so for your first question um we
don't have the breakdowns for the recent
the 2020 information however as as I'm
scrolling through here from our
for here it is the breakdowns for tax
year 18 this is the latest information
but we can get them for tax year 19 as
well
um distributions and dividends made up
the bulk of this tax so if you combine
those you're about 80% of the interest
in dividends tax is made up of
distributions and dividends and then
133% is in interest and in a small
portion of around 8% as federal federal
tax exempt
interest um interest in dividends tax is
a little bit harder to predict uh year
over-year how we got to to these ranges
as we just looked at um past performance
of the taxes um and if you looked at
them fiscal year 19 over fiscal year 18
was about a 7.4% growth and then fiscal
year 20 over fiscal year
um 18 was three and a half%
growth and then we anticipate um you
know some growth this year I think
interest and dividends will be with our
ranges with the anomalous receivable
removed somewhere between seven and
16% so we think that that growth
um the growth will taper off some in 22
and then taper off more in 23 as we've
seen in past performances um I think
partly we're interested in seeing if
some of those dividends and
distributions growth that you spoke of
has to do with some of the repatriated
funds flowing down um to businesses in
20 and 21 I mean excuse me to
individuals in 20 in 21 and that that
may the growth might continue but not as
strong as we were seeing um in in 21 and
then decreasing down to to 23 but again
observation the H the presentation done
by the Dr on the 26th of
January has most of these percentages in
there um like on page 35 of the of their
presentation on the 26 it'll give you
the breakdown of the interest part
dividends distribution and other this so
document represent Aly has a
question yeah thank you on the trouble
is 18 was the year that that they were
repatriating
money if that comes into this tax which
I hadn't thought of it did but maybe it
does yeah I I think you're right for
business taxes that the funds were
repatriated but the distributions being
made may have taken place
um further
21 any further questions on interest and
dividends
then let's move on to Communication
Service
tax okay so for CST we normally just
give a number this this tax doesn't vary
all that much
um we have 38.4 million we we'll keep
updating that I think if you you pick a
number somewhere between you know 37 38
to 40 you're going to fall within the
range with the the the numbers that just
came in for January our new estimate
would be 38.8 so you can see that it
doesn't adjust all that much um and then
we have no growth on this tax for the
next um the next two
CST and on uh CST that normally has been
slowly deing primarily because people
getting rid of their
landlines
you don't you don't see any Decline and
growth in
22 or
23 I think our anticipation is that any
reduction might be offset by the tax law
change for VoIP that occurred where we
gave some clarification on VoIP as well
as um any inclusion in taxes where
taxpayers may not be be in the tax but
may be required to pay the tax like
Zoom again I can't speak to any
particular taxpayers but um taxpayers
that may fall into that
category okay
uh very important one real estate
transfer
tax all right real estate transfer tax
um we know this tax has been doing very
well well
um it came in really well in January
once the revenue Focus comes out you
will see that it performed Almost 100%
ahead of plan um it just it does keep
growing our
low for Real Estate transfer is just
basically basing it on what prior months
um prior months has how excuse me how
prior months have performed
um and we basically just cut in half
what we've seen in the prior months
reducing it from
25% ahead of plan down to 1% for June
that may be a little bit low now as
these revenues obviously keep performing
higher than what we anticipate um them
performing so our height however is
essentially repeating what we saw
December November October and September
and Sor of flipping that to seeing the
reverse amount um for the remaining
parts of this year so February coming in
at 50% and then slowly reducing it um
based on prior year or excuse me the
prior half Trends down to um 133% ahead
of plan in May and then 2% ahead with
June the thought for this is that we're
not sure how high this can go because of
the inventory um demand so we have the
inventory is low which pushes prices
High however how high can those prices
go is the question that we've been
asking um before they just won't go any
further and the demand won't be out
there I think there was some pent up
demand during covid um like I said Home
Improvements H projects happened people
got houses out in the market um which
adjusted our our um our percentages up I
I think every time we come in our
numbers keep getting a little bit higher
and higher so what I did want to note
for January though although that I said
it was 100% PL ahead of plan there was
some anomalous holding company activity
that activity is reported separate from
the counties so it was I want to say
artificially inflated or um it's
inflated and not expected to continue at
that rate um we probably saw it more
around six % ahead of plan without that
holding company activity in there so
we're going from around 60% ahead of
plan for January without that holding
company activity in there reducing it
down to
50% for the high for February or 25% on
the low end for February for the coming
months and then we have some reductions
for 22 and 23 of -7% to 5% and then 8%
to
-6% um we've been trying to watch this
and read as many articles as we can it's
definitely a hard tax to predict just
because of what we've seen with recent
activity um what I think is we're
thinking is that we're going to get back
to where we were um in 22 and 23 prior
to 21 um with a little bit more loss in
23 we're having a hard time thinking
that the continued gain that we've seen
in 21 will continue for 22 and 23 just
based on um if mortgage rates increase
or if that inventory goes too low as
people you know are coming from
um cities and moving into these more
rural
areas happy to answer any
questions represent
El thank you is there anything out there
that is estimating how much of uh
what is being bought is being bought um
by people who are working somewhere else
and are essentially second
[Music]
homeowners planning on moving back or
somewhere else after the the uh covid
danger is over because once that happens
or if that happens our Market is going
to
Crater sure I did read an article and I
will send you over the link um I'm
forgetting where it came from off the
top of my head but it did give a
percentage of how much of the home sales
were coming from at estate buyers um
versus instate
estate okay the utility property tax all
right so the utility property tax we
have um a flat number again I think if
you estimate anywhere between you know
40 and 45 million you'll probably hit it
right on the head we have 43.1 million
um January came in a little bit higher
than we expected so that put our new
estimate probably at 42.3 million with
January data again not too far off from
this 43 million
um this tax this tax we're expected to
um end up with a decrease of 4% below
plan for the fiscal year and we're
questions does anybody have any
questions or comments on utility propit
tax
all
right any questions overall from anybody
committee represent major this is Chris
can I ask Melissa a couple quick
questions just on her numbers
yes Melissa going back to interest and
dividends for 21 you said the range
would be
123.6mi
135.5 yes that's correct okay and then
for the CST if you were to give us a
number it would have been 38.8 based on
what just occurred last month yep and
then for the utility property tax I
didn't hear what you said I apologize uh
42.3 42.3 yes and sorry we just got
those numbers yesterday Chris so yep no
understood and and and just for the me
members of the committee um you should
see a revenue Focus probably tomorrow or
the next day it should be emailed to you
and you would see some of these
percentages that are um being talked
about comparisons of previous year
month-to Monon type of things um if you
don't get the revenue Focus please email
me let me know you didn't get it um if
you don't have anything by
Thursday that way we can just make sure
that they didn't drop you from the
mailing list um but it is a good tool to
if not we thank you Melissa and Devon U
representative major there are two of US
Representative spillsbury has his hand
up and oh okay I didn't see that
representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman this is a question
about the methodology I'm sure this is
well established and been this template
this approach has been used for years
but maybe you can help explain
fy22 your range essentially represents a
pessimistic versus an optimistic
scenario understandable driven by
escalation and then when you move to FY
23 it seems that
the uh the spread in those two scenarios
gets compounded
applying a pessimistic p2's pessimistic
figure and then in the upside on the
high range you're adding a higher
percentage optimistic for
23 onto the higher
number in
fy22 so
on the high side is compounding the high
side of 22 if you look at the range in
dollar figures there's a much narrower
range between low and high forecasted in
fy22 the range becomes much greater or
Amplified in 23 that maybe that can be
explained by the notion that there's
greater
uncertainty the further you look out in
time but it strikes me that it's
primarily driven
by a methodological approach that may be
out I respond to that Melissa sure so
that's a a great question um and I just
want to say I think it's laid out like
this um just for the um committee
benefit so the way Dr would look at it
when we're doing our Reven Revenue
estimates is we are not looking at the
revenue numbers for 22 and 23 we start
with our fiscal year 21 base and then we
pick where we think the growth is going
to fall for 22 or 23 based on our fiscal
year 21 um number we're not doing a low
to low and a high to high I think that's
visually just um giving a range um it is
compounding it I do agree and then when
we look at 22 we now would have our base
for 22 and we would decide what growth
we would apply somewhere between 4 to 6%
based on our our 22
clarify yes so if I'm understanding your
explanation Melissa you're saying that
you're not using the
percentages as the driver for your
projection you've got inde dependent
information that's giving you a figure
and then you're just telling us what it
translates to in percentage terms I
think the opposite sorry if I misspoke
we are using the percentage to determine
our growth off of fiscal year 21 so
fiscal year 21 we would pick a number um
based on where we think it will land um
somewhere in between that range and then
we would grow that fiscal year 21
Revenue estimate by 8 to a if for meals
and rentals for instance by 8 to
11% um depending on where we think 22
will grow so if we thought 22 was was
going to grow at 10% we'd pick our
fiscal year 21 number where we think
it's going to land and then we say
there's going to be a 10% growth on
whatever the number is um for fiscal
year 21 we'd have that number for fiscal
year 22 now that we pick to that growth
and then we'd we'd say okay now for
23 it's going to grow somewhere between
four and 6% looking at economic factors
looking at where we're at where do we
think it would fall would the growth be
between four to 6% so we're really
looking at the growth ranges and not the
spreadsheet so rep of major if I could
just com here as well so repent of uh
spillsbury typically the the ranges are
provided to give the committee an idea
of where do you want to focus your
attention you may end up picking a
number number between we'll use the
meals and Rental a number between 294.50
and 312.50 that is your base number and
then you may make assumptions on what
you believe the growth would be in the
out years so you may say you believe
it's only going to grow 9% and that's
what you would apply or you might say
the range is nine to 10 so that that
you'd have a high low but this is just a
to give the committee a sense of where
to start looking as you try to do your
estimates um you could go outside these
numbers as well if there's re valid
reasons to do so so the Dr has just
provided an opportunity to kind of look
at a range but it's up to the committee
to pick what you want to use as a base
and how you want to grow that or not
grow
it are you all set represent sksb yes
thank you very much for the answers um I
think I need to absorb this as we go on
to really satisfy my question will take
a
while um represent Aly thank you
representative Spiller I think you're
going to get the hang of it as we go
forward we argue 21 numbers then we
argue 22
growth and then we apply that to the
number we got so and I I had just a
quick question about the communication
Services text again do you have a number
for on how much of that growth you just
saw is due to your going after the zoom
like things of which there are
apparently many I only know teams in and
zoom on and I I I think you've been
going after Skype for some time though
haven't you I don't consider that in the
same category but they are I mean
they're huge right now so I wondered if
that's why why um that number went up or
didn't go down in fact um actually it
had nothing to do with either of those
the number went up because um some
payments that were supposed to be made
in December uh December fell further
below plan than anticipated and that was
because payments that were supposed to
be made in December were delayed and
Dr okay well thank you Melissa and
Devon thank you
education we have our work cut out for
ourselves okay we have a little bit of
time um there was one issue that was
brought up and that is relative to House
Bill 346 which we'll be hearing later
on and it doesn't didn't have a fiscal
note in
it but uh Susan did get a fiscal
analysis done so what we need to do is
take a vote of the committee to have the
LBA do a fiscal note so a fiscal note
would be part of the regular record and
the uh public could have access to this
when they looked the bill up right now
all
we it's only us that'll have access to
this fiscal
analysis
representative elme had
done so what I'd like to do is to and
the only way we can get the Dr to do a
fiscal note now is to take a vote and
have the majority the committee agreed
to
that because the since we are in the
regular legislative
process that's what the rules are so I
what I'd like to do is take a
vote
support represent want to say
something one of us
sorry on well it's representative Aly on
I just just wanted to correct one thing
I didn't have the I asked for the fiscal
note but it was done by the agency and
transmitted to Chris Jay and then
transmitted back to
me so I haven't even read it yet I
didn't have
time right it just came in I believe
yesterday
yes um so what I like to do is get the
sense of the
committee the question is
uh if you're in support of requesting a
fiscal note on House Bill
346 you'll reply by saying yes if you're
not you'll reply by saying no so I'd
like representative Bernstein
to call is that a motion
yes just have a second I'll second that
motion representative
shamberg
okay
uh let's get started with representative
AB
bramy representative bramy had to leave
okay representative Mary Griffin is not
here representative
oy State the question
please the question is to request the
LBA to do a fiscal note on House Bill
yes representative obber yes
representative
duet
yes clerical vote
Elliott unmute yourself please
representative
Elliott
you're you're still muted represent
Elliot yes thank you representative
janigian yes representative
Nunes yes representative Baxter I
believe stepped away representative
spillsbury
yes representative tutor yes
me yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative Tucker yes
representative garlo
yes
laughman it's still not
here oh I'm sorry is representative
lofman
here no representative gorg yes
representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Murphy yes
representative major yes 20 to
nil yet for
yes okay
then
Chris Chris Shay yep I so I just wanted
to explain to the committee why why you
had to vote and why there wasn't a
fiscal note um first off the the fiscal
note process is the LSR is submitted by
a prime sponsor for the OS to draft they
have first crack on whe whether a bill
needs a fiscal note or not and then they
would send it to our
office during this um remote time frame
they changed the process for how you
were to um request an LSR and be drafted
it became remote uh an electronic
process and there was a glitch in the
system so when they flagged it for an FN
it didn't always stay on as an FN so
there were some bills that got
introduced that should have had an FN
and didn't get it um so at this point if
you if you're aware of any bill that you
know fits that criteria and the
committee now needs to um per statute
would need to vote um to have us do a
fiscal note and a majority is all that's
needed for the request um in the interim
what we do do is we will do what we call
a fiscal analysis on an amendment or a a
bill um per request of an individual so
in this case representative Aly um
requested for us to look at um House
Bill 346 because she felt that had some
fiscal impact and should be um looked at
so we did that and provided that
document to her which she provided to
repent
major if you debate or discuss um House
Bill 346 you can look at that document
to kind of get a sense of what the
fiscal impact would be of the bill but
that's not an official fcal note it
wouldn't attach to the bill it wouldn't
travel with the bill so what you just
did is required us to actually do an
official fiscal note that would be a
attached to the bill going forward um
and and be available to everybody to see
essentially what repent VY has is a
document that was prepared for her and
how she shares that was is is up to her
to decide um so so again I just wanted
to let the committee know why you did
what you just did um and if you do um
encounter another bill you know that on
your committee that you believe needs
note that doesn't have one this is the
process you would want to
use so I'll and I'll let our office know
ASAP the outside of that I just wanted
to um I should have mentioned earlier
but you should all be receiving in the
mail a packet from our office I don't
know if some of you may have already
gotten it but it's going to have the
caffer a hard copy of the caffer a hard
copy of the offering statement and and
then um the presentation that I provided
you uh you the other day that I did um
so those documents were some that people
were talking about is good resources
particularly the offering statement and
the um caffer um you know if you go into
Pages
146 I think like beginning on 146 of the
caffer you'll find um historical
information on your revenues you have
general fund education trust fund
Highway and fishing game funds um so you
can kind of see some of the trends that
have occurred with those revenues over a
10-year period which may be helpful as
you're thinking about um the volatility
we're dealing with right now also for
the new members um over the summer the
Ways and Means Committee did quite a bit
of work on trying to um determine what
covid what the impact of covid was on
the revenues and um how 21 might end and
what issues were being dealt with a lot
of that information is still on our
website um you may want to take a look
at that as you're trying to understand
potentially what could happen going
forward if if some of these variants uh
you know do Bloom and and become an
issue for for the businesses and others
but again it's a resource um that you
can go back and look at um if you
weren't on the committee at the time
that they that they were being
discussed um trying to think if there's
anything else I can point you at at the
moment but feel free if you have
questions to email myself um happy to
try to search things down for you or or
advise if if I can um again today and
tomorrow are meant to help you educate
yourselves on the types of revenues you
have to look at and why the numbers are
what they are that the agency's provided
so it's all I have thank
you okay um our next session is at
11:30 so representative major yes could
I take a very small amount of that time
first I had my hand
up sure thank you um well first I wanted
to really thank Chris Jay and I think
that I'm at the end of the post office
Pipeline and I got it on Friday Saturday
I forget um that packet could and could
you provide link a link to the co
discussions this summer for the
committee so that they'll know where to
find it
so I can rep me if if anybody's accessed
our website for the um discussions last
week you're going to see revenues and
you'll see 22 23 and then um 2021 if you
go into the 2021 revenues all the
documents are in there and I can put my
screen up if you want me to walk you
through
it can I ask my other question first
because it's something else that you
pointed out there is one other bill that
on is very complicated about needing a
fiscal note hb12 combined worldwide
reporting The Way It Was Written it on
as it says that we need to shift to
worldwide combined reporting which is
another version of uh uh
apportionment uh in the business taxes
and on and to set up a study committee
to consider effects
and on I believe that the sponsor who is
with us here representative shamberg
knows that um it's not completely ready
for prime time yet and because of that
it's going to be very difficult for for
the uh Dr to do a fiscal
note at this point and but it does it
would need a fiscal note if they'd been
paying attention or it hadn't fallen off
the
digital
record so I'm not sure what gets done
with that thank you we'll deal with that
when the bill comes before us and I I
forgot what what day I have scheduled it
for it comes up February
17th it's the yeah it's the last one but
it would definitely need considerable
okay as I was saying we have U 17
the people from HHS comes up come in so
why don't we take a break
until ripson major Ripon Tucker has her
hand
up repres ined Tucker yes
uh the whole time topic of
covid-19 even without variant is one
that is going to have such a big effect
on revenues I really think we need to be
zeroing in
on when it's likely that we'll have a
70% herd immunity in New Hampshire and
the
uh giving out of shots has been so
difficult
with so few vials coming into the
state and some kind of confusion between
the federal approach and the state
approach that I am very concerned that
we're not really going to be ready for a
summer tourist season and that summer
tourist season not only affects the
North country but all of New Hampshire
since tourism is such a big part of our
economy I don't know who would be the
best person to find out uh what the
likelihood of really being open for
business this
summer but I think we need to be asking
that it may be the reopening committee
it may be someone at Dartmouth Hitchcock
it may be health and Human Services or
maybe two or three of those but we need
to get in order to do a proper job of
revenues I really think we need to focus
in on this topic it's it goes through so
many of the uh revenues that it's it's
key you make a very good point and and
we'll make uh room to invite early
people could help uh explain what they
think is going to happen relative to the
vaccine and
you we'll certainly do
that um anything else before we take a a
break if we have time for a break D wz I
just got
back I guess I missed everything why
don't we take a break
until 5 minutes
1125 that that'll make us ready for the
11:25 so don't go away just mute
video
e
Mr chairman could I ask you a question
yes I I was thinking about what
representative Tucker had
mentioned uh and I wholeheartedly agree
I think there's going to be significant
Co impact especially through the summer
and fall months when we have a busy
tourist season and you asking about who
might be um willing to address the
committee to get a sense which I suspect
will be I don't know is what they're
going to say we don't know exactly but
be cautious about predictions and a
suggestion that I would have there's a
few people out there that I think would
have a lot of credibility to present uh
Dr Ben Chan uh who presented to finance
but the other two that are also you know
potential people as Dr Jose uh
Marcato epidemiologist in conquer and
also Dr um Elizabeth Talbot who lives up
in New London but she did a lot of work
with the Ebola virus and all the
epidemiological stuff so what I'm saying
is that these could be three very very
powerful uh resources to give us a sense
about where we're going with vaccine uh
vaccination in the state and what their
predictions might be though their
predictions will be guarded in the sense
that they don't really know but they
will be able to say that to us can you
send me an email I will thank you I'll
give you the three names but each one of
them is an epidemiologist with a lot of
experience and I think they would be
very helpful to present even for a half
an hour with the committee okay thanks
you're
welcome and thank you for me too oh
welcome
I think you're absolutely right you know
about what um the impacts will be going
forward in the The psychosis that people
are going to carry forward as uh the
chairman mentioned even flying too so
while
unfortunately
unfortunately but but I think that's a
different question than the
actual herd immunity which we
need to reach in order to loosen the
restrictions and
regulations yes and when you were saying
that before I was thinking about how you
mentioned New Hampshire her immunity
but I think most of the epidemiologist
you know will tell you that this is a
worldwide her immunity that we need yes
just our tourist season doesn't have
to take that into account as much okay
Chris
yes do we have uh Karen rounds ready yep
um Brad can just bring her into the
meeting and um she's with with you now
okay needs to unmute herself and she'll
be able to
talk okay uh Karen rounds is the Chief
Financial Officer of the Department of
Health and Human
Services and she's going to be here to
talk about the Medicaid
recoveries
R major I'll share my screen just so you
can see the um Medicaid recoveries
column okay and then if you need me to
shut it off just shout at me and I'll
take it down all
right good morning Representatives um
Chris has Meredith joined us I really
need her to be um online to talk through
most of this I I hadn't seen her just
yet but
um I know she is joining so if we can
wait just a moment for her I think this
will be much more efficient with her
joining
us she's with us now Karen well we're
waiting uh do you have any
recommendations on who the committee can
talk with to get a better idea of
uh where covid-19 is going and when
we're going to be able
to get out of
it so I believe um there was a request
that I think it did come from your
committee maybe Chris could uh remind me
for sure to Ben Chan to come present and
I believe that there was a larger
hearing being set up to include more
than just Ways and Means because um Ben
as you can imagine or Dr Chan as you can
imagine is quite busy so we want to make
sure to uh be efficient with his time so
Chris do you recall if that was being
set up I don't know if the larger
meeting with um Dr Chan was being set up
I'm not I'm not involved with that but
you did have um director daily is that
correct I think she came and spoke the
ways and means just to give you a sense
of how the um vaccines were being rolled
out but I'm not sure what's happening
with a larger meeting um with Dr Chan
and any others at this point I'll have
to look into that
okay John Williams is probably the best
contact for that I think he was helping
lead that okay thank
you on he there was a a meeting that I
don't think was terribly well advertised
but that was uh we a number of us were
sent information on with the health and
human services
committee but it was extremely related
to their issues
but they did spend quite a lot of time
in that meeting I don't know if that's
what you were referring to it was
Friday I sat in on it listen to it that
might have been the meeting that was set
up I'm not it was several
hours not just do Dr Chan but others as
well Chris what are what are the columns
all the way to the left I'm assuming
those are labels for each of the fiscal
years on Medicaid
so start so row eight or one depending
how you look at it would be fiscal year
23 there's a p afraid to try to do
anything to the the document because I'm
not sure if I'll lose the image on on
the on the
screen understood maybe if you zoom out
a smidge then we can see those leftand
columns I'm not sure um but I'll go
ahead and just turn it over to Meredith
and and let her
um speak
to the Medicaid
recoveries good morning
everyone uh Meredith tus from the
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm the director of the division of
program quality and integrity uh and
yeah I can walk you through a little bit
of what you're seeing here for the
Medicaid
recoveries areas um you'll see that the
estimates are going down year-over-year
uh much more slightly between 22 and
23 and you may recall when we presented
last week that they had his historic
historically um for these two years
which I think was around 201 17ish um 16
17 they had been very high like in the
$9 million range um that was because at
the time the department um had been
awaiting cost settlements to happen uh
with hospitals for their Medicare audits
to be completed and those had gotten
backed up for a long time period
um and and then finally kind of were
were many audits were completed and so
there's kind of a flood of cost
settlements occurring and so we had this
influx of Revenue over a couple of years
um that is now completed and the cost
settlements are much more standardized
and the timing of them is um ongoing so
we're really up toate on getting those
cost settlements done for our outpatient
payments to hospitals so we don't really
anticipate that part of Revenue
fluctuating going forward so our our
Medicade recoveries are made up of a few
different areas um that I'm going to
categorize four ways one is those cost
settlements which as I said kind of had
fluctuated previously and we expect them
to be much more standard going forward
one is the area of program
Integrity which is recoveries for
provider or beneficiary fraud was or
abuse one is TPL which is third party
liability because as you're all probably
aware Medicaid is the pair of Last
Resort and then one is estate recoveries
Medicaid estate
recoveries so um in the area of program
Integrity which relates to provider
um fraud waste and abuse or beneficiary
fraud waste and abuse we've seen very
slight
changes um in that there's a a a small
increase in uh recoveries on the
provider side and I think that's for a
um one being that the the uh Attorney
General's office to whom we refer
Medicaid fraud um has had had a lot less
turnover recently and so they are kind
of standardizing their
processes
um
however that that has been kind of a
recent development in the last 12 months
what
happened um previously is that the
department entered into of course
contracts with our managed care
companies and the Managed Care
organizations now hold the vast majority
of the Medicaid population for the
department so they are are really doing
the recoveries for waste and abuse which
is the bulk of the recoveries is small
small amount of Fraud and then the
majority is waste and abuse um and so
the Managed Care organizations then
retain those recoveries and we don't see
them here now that does mean that on
that side of of the department paying
the Managed Care organizations we can
reduce our payments to them based on
those recoveries we know they're going
to receive but what it means is that
what this committee sees in terms of
general fund revenues is reduced
slightly from that from that
change um so that is recoveries from
Medicaid
providers recoveries from um Medicaid
beneficiaries actually at this point we
have discontinued pursuing uh recoveries
from beneficiaries unless there is is
fraud in which case it's referred to law
enforcement we're awaiting guidance from
CMS as our all states on what they
intend for us to do with recoveries uh
for Medicaid
beneficiaries for um for overpayments
medical
overpayments related to um
beneficiaries and then uh on the third
party well I'll stop there that's
program Integrity um and let me ask do
people have questions on program
Integrity
recoveries representative major you're
you're there there we go before we get
into that would you give us some idea
what the
magnitude of the Medicaid payments
all Medicaid payments or Medicaid
payments to the Managed Care
organizations
or what's here all Medicaid
payments um I think Karen will know
better but I believe it's around two
billion or a little over two billion
it's somewhere in that range it's like
1.6 to two depending on uh many factors
in one year or two years that's a
year okay that's all Medicaid programs
too so that's like croch share and uh
the DD system and long-term care that
that's everything and then the relation
recoveries from that amount or what
amount would they recover from what what
group R is so the recovery that we would
be engaged in would be for primarily
Medicaid providers where we
see fraud or waste or
abuse or other types of overpayments so
on medic providers how much money is
providers how much money is paid out to
asking uh it is the the same amount as
what Karen is saying but it's made in
different forms so some of the payments
that we make are fee for service
based
um because we still have a fee for
service population some of them are fee
for service on the long-term care side
and then I want to say
around um uh around 1 billion Karen goes
organizations and I think um is that
does that sound right about a billion
yeah that sounds about right I mean I
I'd want to confirm to but something
around that it's something like a
billion goes to the Managed Care
organizations and then we have kind of
what I'll call Bulk payments um of
around you know 250 million-ish in Dish
and then Pro
share um so they're not so the payments
are not always made from the Department
directly to Providers as a fee for
service
payment so what I'm trying to get at is
the $3.7 million in
to what's the part of money that were
paid out by medic
Cade that they look for recoveries for I
believe our feif for service
payments um I would need to check on
that number I just don't have it off the
top of my head like is it a half a
billion dollars worth of
payments a billion or a tenth of a
billion if we include long-term care I
think our long-term care payments total
million yeah if you include the CFI
waiver it's like 370 I think
370 what do you what are you trying to
does the 3.7 million represent
out we would have to we would have to
look at that um
I think representative I just want to
make sure we're capturing the right
amount for
comparison and then can give you the
categories let's say it's money to
provide is was was a100
million and is this recovery all from
that $100 million that was paid out or
what
else is theover recovery
represent other than money paid out to
Providers part of this would be
Providers
um hard yes yes it would be money paid
out to
Providers and uh and then the other
portion of it though is estate
recoveries so estate recoveries for
people who have been receiving
Medicaid
all right represent major representative
AB bramy has had his hand
up representative
BR sure thank you um I remember from
years ago one example of this that fell
into this bucket was people who who
received uh benefits or payments uh were
made for under Medicaid but then you
discover that they actually had other
insurance ins and that you CW you clawed
back that money from the other insurance
is that correct that's correct and that
is what we referred to as TPL or third
party liability because Medicaid is the
pair of Last Resort that's correct
representative and what what percentage
of of the total here are we talking is
that a pretty big percentage of what
you're Co you're
recovering it is I will try to find a an
amount for it's a little over um
a half a million dollars it might be in
the range of six to
700,000 right okay but on that side
something to keep in mind is that
similar to program Integrity when we
moved into uh Managed Care the Managed
Care organizations took over that
function of TPL so they are now
responsible for doing TPL on their
members they have access to the other
insurance we provide them access to who
has medic care and they should primarily
be cost avoiding which means when a
claim comes in for someone who has third
party liability they deny it in the
first instance so I know it's
counterintuitive but we actually don't
want to see a ton of recoveries for TPL
because we want them to cost avoid the
claim first um and we kind of check
their systems to make sure that's what
they're doing but then in addition to
that yes if if for some reason it wasn't
a ailable to them that information and
they paid the claim then they would do
the recovery on the back end so that
that kind of explains that the reduction
is that part of the explanation of why
this number is going down over time it
is it is um and so actually while the
mco's manag Care organizations have been
doing those cost recoveries for us
related to medical and Pharmacy claims
um for some time in our contracts we
just moved accident and Trauma subreg
into the contracts as of last fall so
that's a new area that they will be
covering that we won't be covering and
that's why we anticipate it going down a
little further over the coming years
okay that's great thank you y and just
to to reiterate while we see a reduction
here we are gaining in our contracts
with the mcos because we force a
side all right go ahead followup
question representative major this is
Dick
Ames represent Ames yeah um on estate
recoveries is that the same picture are
the managed care companies now doing
some of that it's not um we continue to
do that and estate recoveries has
actually been um doing pretty well I
don't have the the graphs but if you
refer to the graphs that we had provided
from last week you'll see that one's
been incrementally ticking up um as our
estate recoveries group has just really
been doing a doing a a very good job um
I think they'll probably Plateau at some
point there's only so much there but
that has been increasing I I want to say
it's around
1.5 million of recovery that they're at
now thank
you okay you can
continue so those are actually all four
areas of uh Medicaid recoveries it's
really the ACT um the thirdparty
liability program Integrity estate
recoveries and uh cost settlements so at
this point while they continue to go
down slightly or we anticipate them
going down slightly it is because we
anticipate more action happening in the
Managed Care sphere and the department
will be like I said sa kind of
saving um an equal amount in those
[Music]
contracts
any
questions uh
representative Philips thank you Mr
chair um miss too if you could just
speak a little bit to about the
proportion of what portion the
beneficiaries are no longer being um
pursued in terms of by the department
for those
collections um related to those um
program Integrity concerns you just
spoke about you said you are continuing
to follow the provider fraud use abuse
and waste but uh the collections for the
beneficiaries you're you're not
currently pursuing those and just
referring those to law enforcement my
concern is you know what is kind of like
the average threshold of those
collections that you could pursue and
also like the bigger pie picture how big
is that P piece of the pie that we're
not actually tracking
down so I can look into historically
what those amounts were we are still
recovering um on our on our uh member
fraud side
um but I I think you know um recoveries
might be 5 to 10,000
um uh a month so it would be it would be
maybe up to 120,000 is a year um so
not huge numbers and part of the reason
I think that a lot of states are in this
position of questioning where they go
with this is because of course we're now
in a situation where we are paying
Managed Care organizations premium every
month for certain
members um if a member does not utilize
their uh
Medicaid um and then we find something
happened and they weren't discontinued
for a few months the states are
questioning are do we pursue that um if
it's not
fraud so that's really the outstanding
question but if you are curious what it
had been historically I can certainly
you okay what those recoveries had been
kind of when we were in a feif for
service
world and Mer is so that if you have a
total of 1.2 billion dollars in in
Medicaid
expenditures we're recovering about
onethird of 1% due to fraud or third
third party billing other other things
1% if um I think we need to look at what
our portion of payments directly to
Providers is though the portion that's
outside of the Managed Care world and
outside of proch share payments and
outside of dish payments and and then
see what that total is and I I don't
have that total in front of me um Mr
chair so I will try to look at what that
total is okay so you're saying there's
recoveries on these other
areas those are those are separate yes
those are separate from the recoveries
that we do in for program Integrity for
example so when we make the dish
payments the recovery on that is a
totally different mechanism that
wouldn't wouldn't show up in our
Medicaid recoveries right and these
recoveries go to the general CL all
those all those other recoveries go to
specific dedicated areas
the well for dish for example those
recoveries are redistributed among the
hospitals okay something to keep in mind
too is that as Karen and I are
discussing when we talk about
percentages as Karen and I are
discussing the um payments to Providers
those are total funds what you're seeing
here is just the general fund portion
there's a federal fund match here that's
also recovered but provided back to the
uh to the feds back to CMS so this is
just
representing half or less than half of
the total recoveries based on whatever
questions I I don't see any further
Aly no I think the part of this elephant
that we are seeing is getting shrinking
down to a less than a toenail over the
years as as they hopefully get more
efficient with the use with the hmos and
all
that
okay S no F further questions thank you
presentation thank you very
much Norm can I make a
comment yes P yeah during the break I
got a call this is not on this on
revenues um I got a call from dve juv at
the business industry
Association he wanted to talk about the
uh House Bill uh 281 the uh single sales
Factor Bill he wanted me to know that he
wanted us to know that they are not
taking a position on this bill because
their membership is totally split on it
um matter of fact he he's invited me I'm
going to speak to the finance committee
of that Association on the 12th to talk
about it uh along with one of the
members on the commission that we were
on Carl I can't remember his last name
now one of the accountants is going to
be speaking on that so but the news is
that they're
split uh which is interesting uh which
tells me that their perception is
there're going to be some winners and
some
losers and uh depending on the kind of
business they're in that's what it means
yep
okay I just want everybody to know that
good I'll update everybody after that
meeting any other good information for
anybody say again directly to me Norm um
okay
question represent Aly you have your
hands
up you're muted
represent yeah and I was wondering if we
could get the Bia to provide somebody
from each side of that to talk to us
yeah norm since we've got the bill right
problems any further comments or
break if not then uh will be back at one
o'clock and there'll be uh
representatives from the highway fund
Steve Lavoy Scott BR Donna Raymond Marie
Mullen will be talking to us about that
and then the J judicial branch right
after that all right when do you expect
it will be done today we should be done
I Would S by 2 o'clock okay
thank
you that's my best guess best guess I
know that's all we do
here okay you can mute
yourself about the video and the audio
o'clock
e
for
representative major
yes uh over the lunch hour I was just
listening to a just as another an FYI
another um um webinar from New London
Hospital uh
on covid-19 where we heading that sort
of thing is by Michael Calderwood which
is actually very good um so he's another
one that could potentially be in our
queue of speakers for all of this stuff
minutes
I'm checking my emails and uh Jim I just
got your email yep and the other name is
Michael Calwood and I'll send you that
as well he's actually very good good
you
e
1:00 I hope everybody had something good
to eat I just want to remind the members
that uh this noon time I had an
opportunity to talk to the governor's
budget
director and the governor is going to be
presenting his budget to the finance
committee on the
17th and the governor's budget director
will be uh talking to our committee on
the 18th at 9:00 for two hours relative
to the revenue estimates that were used
in the Governor's budget so we'll have
an opportunity to go over
that with the governor's budget
director also I see that Chris has sent
the link to all the documents and
that uh before we get started with the
uh
Highway like to have Chris go through
the uh the worksheet associated with the
highway
CR thank you rep some major I'm going to
uh screen share the single page document
with you and just kind of walk you
through
that so you should be seeing um Highway
fund Revenue estimates in thousands has
Department of Safety in the first
row so when U Mr laevo and Mr Brier came
in and spoke with you the other day they
provided estimates on the road
toll on the on the motor vehicles and
then
miscellaneous and what I did is I just
rolled up to the subtotals for each of
those there's detail behind each one of
these
lines and in the M on R 11 the MV
miscellaneous that's where the judicial
branch um estimates are also contained
typically but because the judicial
branch and Department of Safety were
slightly different in some of their
estimates I broke it out starting on
line
15 not and no neither one is right or
wrong it's just different approaches
different um ideas on what they they're
seeing or expect to have happen going
forward but I just wanted the committee
to see on rows 17 and 18 um the slight
differences between what they were
estimating as you're thinking about
ranges and what you want to project for
the unrestricted Highway fund and then
on excuse me and then on line 23 is the
Department of Transportation they have a
small amount of Revenue it's about
$200,000 um that they project and that's
typically related to land sale or um
property that was bought with Highway
funds and it goes back into the highway
fund so that that's the one pager and
then in the worksheet there's a page
that rolls us up even tighter where
you'd only have the line of road toll
motor vehicle and miscellaneous so I
believe for the conversation to start
you'd want to um we'll reference this
tool and today you know I invited um Mr
Lavoy uh Mr Brier um Mr Raymond from the
judicial branch and Marie Mullen from do
aailable to talk to you and to help you
um understand any any uh transactions
that occur with the highway
fund so I'll leave it at that and um
major thank you Chris and who wants to
start off with the highway fund Steve
Lavoy who's the director of
administration for the Department of
Safety
good morning representative can you hear
me
yes um so as we presented last week um
we we took a relatively conservative
approach with our with our estimates um
and and really broke this up into two
sections uh of considerations so the
road toll is the area that has been
impacted the most by the p
pic continues um to be impacted by the
pandemic motor vehicle revenues have
been relatively
stable throughout the P we expect them
to stable moving
forward um so our our road toll
estimates um one of the questions that
came up prior uh during our presentation
had to do with how do we account for um
EV
Vehicles move to electric vehicles
and um I think I think um the the the
the way that we account for that is is
not for Ev vehicles in and of themselves
because we're not expecting a c change
in Behavior over the next bium in 22 and
23 there will be more people adopting um
moving from combustion to EV vehicles
but we're expecting the rates to be
consistent with the prior years um uh
rate of of trans those types of Vehicles
we're also expecting uh fuel efficiency
rates to continue to improve um which
would typically put downward pressure on
um on on gasoline usage and therefore on
the road toll uh but if if if you recall
from our uh previous presentation when
we provided numbers from 16 through 23
the period from fy6 through FY uh 18 and
19 we're still seeing a one about a 1%
increase year over year even as uh fuel
efficiency is improving even as people
are starting to adopt um electric
vehicles um we we are assuming that
similar uh type of of rate of increase
between 22 and 23 and that's what you're
seeing here in the road toll the change
from 12.3 million to
121.5 million um we're just not
expecting within the next bium um we're
not expecting all of the conditions that
would be necessary to be present for a
big change in driver o uh electric
vehicle ownership so there's still a
significant way for us to go in the
state for infrastructure as far as uh
charging stations especially fast
charging stations um we also as you know
we're a rural state so there's I think R
range anxiety in um in our our residents
than we do um in some other more
metropolitan areas um if you're going
into the North country and you're hiking
for the day you're going to be concerned
if your electric vehicle has enough uh
Power has enough energy to get you back
home if it's a two-hour drive one way um
and so uh and we also don't have any
State uh tax incentives uh for Ev
ownership um like some other states
might have so that that's not going to
be an incentive for people to to be
early adopters so because of those
factors while while there will be an
increase in the number of EVS we don't
believe it'll be significant enough to
change our um our approach for
estimating revenues in 22 and 23 uh and
so that's essentially what we've done uh
here with the road
toll motor vehicle Revenue estimates are
relatively straightforward um as I
mentioned
registration um haven't been significant
issues there from a pandemic perspective
we still believe people are going to be
um registering their vehicles they
they're required to by law um motor
vehic operators same situation in 22 and
23 you do see an increase but that has
to do with the the dip year that occurs
um every five years and so we're
currently in the dip year in
fy21 uh will be out of the dip year in
22 and so we're expecting the licensing
license return to normal levels in 22
and 23 inspections and titles are two
areas that are also flat um from a from
a regular year year perspective for DMV
revenues haven't been impacted by the
pandemic and we expect them to remain
relatively flat moving forward into 22
and 23 um the miscellaneous uh line um
that did get an an increase from prior
years because that's where the plea by
mail revenues are being
recorded um and um that's that's
essentially what you're seeing there is
is as traffic volume returns to normal
levels uh pre-pandemic levels we would
expect that the number uh of tickets
would also increase and that the
corresponding revenues would increase as
well and so our estimates in 22 and 23
uh reflect that increase going from 11.6
take St I'm sorry I couldn't hear you uh
would you take any questions now
yeah absolutely any questions at all and
I do have Scott Brier who's the um the
Euro chief of road toll available with
me today as well representative
bronley actually a roto question but I
I'll ask it if if uh if you feel more
comfortable with Mr Brier answering at
that time so you know back in uh 2020
the plan was 127 million doll for road
toll uh we came in at 117.8 that's
because I'm of what happened that last
quarter I imagine with the uh everything
shutting down and then and then you you
have it going up but you have it going
up in 23 up to only
121.5 million so and we were in pretty
good shape at 127 million plan so we're
still way under what the that plan was
from two years ago from when we we
estimated a couple years ago so what I'm
getting at did you did you did you
factor in any change in uh post covid
that more people will continue to work
at home because businesses have
discovered that hey we don't need these
offices anymore CO's gone but business
practic has changed less commuters have
you factored that into your thinking
yeah we we we absolutely did so we um
two two levels of that one is less
commuters as are assuming that people
will be commuting down as you know many
people who live in New Hampshire work in
Massachusetts or in the neighboring
states but primarily in Massachusetts
and in the Boston area and we um we are
assuming that a lot of those commuters
will will remain working from home if
not 100% of the time a significant
portion of the time and maybe they only
need to go to the office once a week or
once a month or or or some sort of
arrangement like that um we also needed
to consider some of the increases that
we've seen during the pandemic which had
helped to Bo raise our our revenues we
had neighboring um folks who were
visiting the state uh because there
weren't other options and they couldn't
travel uh across the country or they
weren't comfortable traveling by plane
um or or going uh internationally so we
uh if you recall in the summer we had
lots of people hiking um and that was
causing its own its own problems we
don't expect that's going to continue
indefinitely either so we'll go back to
our more normal
um um kind of uh more normal tourism and
travel levels so our assumptions for our
22 and 23 estimates um we're assuming
that the the level of change from
preco to postco would result in about a
7% decrease in um in usage and fuel
usage across the board so that would be
the combination of people who are no
longer commuting combined with people
who have been cooped up and don't want
to be uh staying in the state but are
going to leave and fly um and um for for
their vacations moving forward so that
that um as I mentioned before we're
conservative with our estimates that's a
conservative number um that's really
something that um that the committee
would need to discuss and decide what
the correct number would be we
originally talked about a 5% um
Plateau but some of the um some of the
recent Revenue collections on the road
toll in the past several months led us
to revise that down to 7% because we
were seeing a recovery that was headed
towards that 5% number U but it dropped
off significantly and it dropped off
before kind of that second wave started
you can see a correlation with the
second of covid um but but it's really
tied into into the um the tourism
seasons and the shoulder season after
the weather started um getting cooler
but before the snow flies that period of
time saw a significant decline in in
traffic um and and Scott if you want to
jump in at any point to to add any
please um I don't have anything really
to add what Steve saying is pretty
accurate and basically after the Fage
season that's when we started seeing a
decline are you all set representative
Bry that's a followup or actually a
different question um I know Turnpike
money isn't in here at all but do you
have a access to Turnpike data like the
Easy
Pass can you tell from the Easy Pass um
ownership uh which vehicles are from out
of state or in state is that something
that's P or allowed or how do you how do
you get your estimate of out of-state
Travelers more or less is is that one of
the ways you can do that that would be
one of the ways I I I defer to dot on on
what type of data is available through
the Easy paath System I'm not sure um
I'm not sure what that looks like but we
we do um dot shares some of their
traffic reports with us on a regular
basis which helps us to um project
what's coming and um align with what
we're seeing from road toll Collections
and um you know we we would see a
correlation between the traffic on the
turnpike system and then a decline in in
road toll revenues they also have
traffic counters throughout the state
that aren't on the main highways but on
the other thorough fairs and and
anecdotally what we've seen and again
dot is really the P the the the agency
that should be speaking to this but from
the data that they shared with us um and
from discussions we've had it appeared
that the local traffic level was
starting to come back to to to closer to
normal levels it was the interstates and
the Turnpike system travel that spiked
in the Summer started really coming back
and then dropping off significantly so
you can make some assumptions there even
without the easy pass that a lot of that
traffic is coming from out of state um
and then anecdotally too um you know
just looking around if if I did some
hiking this summer as well I saw the m
chuses plates everywhere um I've done
skiing with with with my I've gone
skiing with my daughter this this season
there's a lot of out estate plates um in
the Lots so you know combining all those
factors together it does seem like we're
still getting a lot of Tourism traffic
um that's that that's obviously they're
purchasing fuel when they're in the
State uh best case scenario I just want
to agree with you on that I did some
hiking this summer and every time
I and it's like 50 over 50% of the
plates are out of state mostly Mass some
Elliot unmute yourself
Bob Bob you're muted can you hear me now
yes uh this is a personal question uh
for Steve L um is there because of the
corona
19 uh effect on the certificates of
titles being issued is it slowed it down
significantly because uh a couple of
months ago I paid off my car and I'm
have yet to see the retitle to it and my
wife has a new car and she doesn't have
a title to it is there a problem with
the issuances of certificates of
title um so I wouldn't say there's a
problem but there's certainly a delay um
the the DMV has been impacted as as All
State agencies have with the the revenue
constraints that we faced and the hiring
freeze that was put into place to make
sure that um you know we minimize the
impact on of declining revenues on the
state budget and so unfortunately that
that has caused delays in some areas uh
and and title processing um hasn't
hasn't escaped so there are there are
some delays in title processing but it
really has to do with Staffing levels um
a combination of both vacancies that uh
we haven't been able to fill due to a
lot of these Revenue constraints we're
talking about today that we're seeing in
fy21 um and then also due to um covid
protocols so if uh somebody's family
member were exposed and if they're
unable to um uh if if they're required
to quarantine uh they can't come in to
work and process those titles so uh
that's a challenge that DMV faces on a
daily basis uh director B is always
looking at her Staffing levels and
shifting resources as best as she can um
but but you're right you're not you're
you're not alone in seeing some of those
delays um I can just uh let you know
that that DMV is aware of them and
they're working as hard as they can to
hire new people and keep the staff
levels as high as they can be given the
downward pressure we're facing on our
revenues
okay thank you I'll give you another
month thank
committee I don't see any hands raised
Steve
stra did we lose I was just disconnected
am I am I back there you go all right
yes okay um so so we talked about road
vehicle fees oh and now my video's on
thank you Chris
hello got it I noticed my camera wasn't
on I had asked him if he could turn it
on so um hi everybody the so if we move
on to the um I guess really probably the
judicial branch motor vehicle finds
collection is the next area that we
would talk about um and and Chris Shay
had mentioned that our estimates
differed slightly with uh the judicial
branch estimates and and from the
judicial branch and I connected on those
because we just wanted to make sure that
you know we weren't missing something
and at the end of the day I think it
really just comes down to um two
different approaches on um and and two
different assumptions on on where these
these fees will be so this has to do
with court fines um so they're motor
vehicle fines but they're collected
through the courts and um we did see
some growth year-over-year growth
recover recovery I should say recovery
from prior uh declines over the over the
last several months and and what Doss
did was we projected that out assuming
that we would have continued rates of
growth in those areas and we ended up at
4.3 million um so obviously the judicial
branch had 3.9 not too far off and and I
don't want to speak for them they they
can Donna could jump in at any time um
for 22 our estimates are very close and
then for 23 is where we start to di
diverge a bit uh we're projecting
similar rates to pre-co levels uh
because as I mentioned we're we're
thinking that traffic will recover even
if it's not commuting traffic we're
still going to have more people on the
roads uh so there'd be more violations
uh and so we're expecting in 23 those
amounts to kind of to recover back
closer to preco levels the 4.8 million
is still a decline year-over-year
if you went back to fy19 we still we're
we're still being conservative there um
the the the judicial branch estimate is
just even more conservative than that uh
because they had noted a downward Trend
in revenues for motor vehicle fines um
and extended that Trend further um and a
bit more aggressively than we had
decided to so um and I think uh I I do
believe that Donna Raymond is on is on
the call um and she could jump in and
provide some more color on the judicial
branch estimate if if that's something
the committee would like Donna you want
to make comments
on the judicial branch numbers yeah yes
good afternoon um so yeah as Steve
mentioned I am a little more
conservative I think by Nature anyways
but I am trying to base it on data that
I have observed um through now
December's um and January's figures as
well um but we are seeing a little bit
of growth um which is um encouraging
about
6% I think so that is reflected in our
fiscal year 21 projections and then in
fiscal year
22 excuse me I am still continuing to
see expect some growth but also what is
reflected in that number is the Court's
continued processing of backlog because
as has been mentioned in this meeting
the courts have also Court staff have
also been impacted by covid following
the protocols of someone either test
positive has been around somebody who
was tested positive is caring for
someone in their home that type of thing
the Circuit Court which processes um the
motor vehicle finds mentioned that
couple of months ago about 25% of their
staff were out at one time or another
dealing with covid related issues so it
did impact the ability for the courts to
continue to process these cases in a
timely manner so the ick um in that
you're seeing in fiscal year 22 is
reflecting the continued catchup of
those cases I'm assuming by the time
fiscal year 23 rolls around the courts
will have been caught up I'm hoping in
the next six months that will be the
case but with other things going on with
these new covid variants that are out
there and the uncertainty about those I
don't want to be too um optimistic about
that I'd rather be a little more
conservative so again um by the time
fiscal year 23 rolls around assuming
that the additional revenues that you're
seeing as a result of catchup are no
longer there but I wanted to reflect
this downward Trend that we have
continued to see I think since fiscal
year
2016 and I you know I've often pondered
what causes that I mean it's
year-over-year it is consistent it is
undeniable now I know I believe back on
January 1 of
2016 about eight um motor vehicle um
case uh motor vehicle um ppes that had
been musters were changed to plea by
mail so yeah I would expect that a lot
of people would take advantage of the
ple by mail option and so we would um
see a reduction in our revenues based on
those eight um citation types whereas
safety would see an uptick um from those
and then the other thing that changed I
believe I don't know if it was exactly
the same time but right around the same
time was um some of the highway speeds
were increased in the uh North part of
the state from 65 to 70 so again you
would see less you would expect to see
less tickets being issued as a result of
that um but again we're going back five
years now why do we continue to see this
downward this you know undeniable
downward Trend and I've been pondering
how we could get at that um and I really
don't know anything other than to look
at bu you know citation type the amounts
that are being issued so we kind of get
a baseline are we seeing Trends there we
have to look at it over the years and
then of those how many of them are plea
by mail and of those that are actually
ple by mail how many people choose to do
that how many people choose um to
contest it go to the courts and then
what is the outcome
so what I'm trying to say is I think
it's possible to get at this data but I
think it would be a lot of work but I
don't know any other way to try to
untangle this because other than those
two factors that I mentioned um I don't
really know other significant changes
that would account for this Contin
seeing um Donna on The Plea by
then
um it isn't no no it's an opportunity
for you to maybe maybe have your fine
reduced or not issued at all but if you
are found guilty you you pay that that
amount I guess is the way I should
answer
that okay but that doesn't explain why
return I don't think so I mean again is
that you you'd have to look at it over
the years and say are less tickets being
issued you it could start from there but
we don't know unless we look at the data
it's really hard to say
okay representative BR
me
got there I got it okay I had I had to
get to the button thank you um uh
represent a major so uh so we got three
factors here less cars on the road would
probably impact less tickets we got ple
by mail which you can match up with uh
you know the other side in terms of
those are getting the plea by mail but
the backlog um on the backlog so how
many of these cases are jury cases vers
is just going before a judge I would
imagine they'd be less likely to have
jur 12 people juries jurors sitting next
to each other in the co times versus
just having a
judge U hearing correct I would not
expect that very many if any of these
are jury I think they're all yeah and I
would think a lot of them don't even go
before a judge you may be um meeting
with the
prosecutor to discuss the case just
playing out or something yes right yeah
okay thank
you represent
alamy thank you I I was Wonder Don't You
have records of how many of the cases
are motor vehicle fins
and Department of Safety have records of
how many tickets they issue and get
fines back for that could just be added
together well
I believe at the end of the day safety
would have all of the information
because it starts with somebody issuing
a citation to someone which is on
safety's end then it's a matter of is
excuse me is the citation um eligible
for plea by mail some of them are must
appear they coming to the court
regardless but safety would know that
then it would also know if they are plea
by mail right but then of those that are
CLE by mail do people wish to contest
them then it comes over to us but
eventually there is some resolution to
the case either excuse me they're found
guilty and have to pay it or they um
they're found not guilty for whatever
reason and they don't have to pay it and
then that information gets sent back
over to safety so I believe that like I
said at the end of the day all of it
rests with safety we the courts would
not know about the plea by Mals because
safety and if I
may
Steve um yeah so so don is Don is
absolutely correct um you know if you
think of the citations they're being
issued by State Police and they're being
issued by local PDS um we have um an
electronic ticketing system which state
police utilizes and many local PDS
utilize which allows us to capture that
data very easily those local PDS that
aren't using e ticketing um are using
paper tickets and those are all coming
in and have to be entered in uh on a
very manual basis so if you look at the
driver of this Revenue the first driver
really is tck volume of tickets being
written um and that's the that's the
piece that we need to determine what's a
reasonable estimate which will bring us
back down to um the first level piece
which will bring us back down to um um
the the uh you know how many tickets are
being are being um issued is that is a
measure of how much traffic is on the
roadways how many officers are available
to issue tickets um th those types of
factors then the split occurs The Plea
by mail is easy because it's the it's
this it's the written um posted fee that
will be paid uh the court fine component
there might be an adjustment and so
that's where um there's an opportunity
for um for for the judges to to
potentially um wave the fee entirely or
reduce the fee amount due to um
inability to pay or hardship or those
types of things so there's a lot of
leeway um and that that's another layer
of of um
uncertainty that falls into this level
of um of Revenue Source here so even if
we know the total ticket amount we're
not going to know how that's going to be
adjusted in in 2023 if people are
contesting them in in in the courts so I
think I think what it comes down to is
you know safety and um the two different
estimates are are assuming a different
Baseline level of ticketing because
eventually we're seeing a decline but
the decline won't go to zero the decline
will eventually level off and be the new
Baseline we're assuming that new
Baseline would bring us to about 4.8
million um and and the judicial branch
is assuming that new Baseline would
just a question uh of interest on a ple
by male what is the range of fines on
these play by
males oh gosh I don't know off the top
of my head but um one of the changes
that Donna mentioned at the beginning
those were the highpe speed finds that
used to be must appears I think those
were up to 4 $400 um those are some of
the highest fines um and then and then
the lowest the lowest fines you know a
lot a lot lower than that but uh I'm
just going off of memory um I could
certainly get actual figures for you but
it's
usually up it could be up to around
$400 but on the low part um typically if
you go through a stop sign or if you're
what would typically be the cost of one
of
these um I don't know off the top of my
head I'm I'm gonna see if I can pull
this up very quickly
here originally ask is because if you're
talking 50
$75 it may be cheaper for somebody that
has to deal with this rather than taking
a day off work Transportation cost and
all that is cheaper than
yep so I'm looking at the uniform fine
schedule right now um that lists all of
these
violations um and um it looks like you
know there's three pages four pages of
violations here it looks like the most
common amount is about
$62 um that's failure to dim parking
lights failure to Le yield to an
emergency vehicle um it looks like
lowest okay that gives me an
idea um the highest fine on here just
for point of reference
is um it looks like it's refusing
inspection for a DED fuel DED special
$40 there certainly wouldn't be many of
those I would hope
not but as as far as
speeding how fast do you have to go and
meal
[Music]
um how fast
for for what the the highest amount to
make it not eligible make it not
eligible um it looks like so all of that
was the change that that occurred all
the speeding tickets are now can now be
pled by mail it used to be that the
highest rat so 21 over or more over the
limit those I believe those used to be
um uh must appears those have changed so
now in a if you're speeding 26
miles an hour or more over the limit in
a 55 it's a
$434 fine in the past that was a must
appear at the
courts
questions okay I don't see anybody with
raised um do you have anything else
to oh
yeah uh NOP just I'm available if uh if
the committee has any questions
throughout the process uh we're more
than happy to uh to provide any
information we have Scott do you have
anything else to contribute to
this okay again um I have I have nothing
else but I mean if it's some questions
anybody has i''d be happy to answer them
uh representative
browny looking at the uh uh the two the
two numbers for the uh for the two out
years so we have uh actually when you
add the two together they're they're
they're almost identical safety's
estimate on fines and judicial branches
estimate on fines so if we got 4.5 and
4.6 that's
9.1 and then when we add the the last
year that's 4.8 and 4.1 is 8.9 so you're
only off by 0.2 when you add them
together so
you know I think one is estimating less
judicial branch uh for their reasons and
and probably safety you're you're
projecting more maybe you're
anticipating more of those uh plea by
males and and judicial is estimating
less less ple by male so so but the
estimates come in very close for those
observation
27 uh shows the total
revenue going from 238 and 21 to
flat so represent major if I might so
that's includes the um safety estimate
on from Seven line
17 and then line 28 is the judicial
branch um estimates that are on line 18
is almost the same Yep they're very
close and I just wanted to make sure the
committee was aware there was a slight
difference between the two estimates I
didn't um wasn't trying to create a a
bigger issue than might be there but
just so that you were aware there might
be a slight range
okay uh any further questions from the
committee
stand thenone we want to thank Steve
Scott Donner and
Maria for coming to prevent present
their information and thank
you thank you and rep represent major
Don is gonna stay on the line and talk
to you about the Court's um unrestricted
general fund Revenue oh okay yeah so I'm
gonna stop this year and put that
up
[Music]
be so when you look at this it's um I
column I so those are the court fing
fees the unrestricted general fund
Revenue
um so if there was any question specific
to that Donna would be able to address
that for you today she gave a a fair
amount of detail in her presentation the
other
day um but I'm sure she's happy to
address any questions you
have let call
sheets
Donna you want to say anything first
us um I guess what I would just say um
kind of reiterating what I said in my
presentation last week is um this is uh
a several different um streams of
Revenue going into this total that you
see and the largest amount um of this is
what we call other fees but around 65
75% of other fees is uh Records
research and that has continued to
perform quite strongly um despite the
pandemic and uh as I had mentioned last
week I think New Hampshire's economy has
actually fared better than a lot of
States uh in the country as a result of
the pandemic and we're still seeing a
very strong housing market and so we
have people calling in to do records
checks on people who may be um renting
from them we also have people who
continue to employ individuals and want
to do records checks so that has
continued to do quite well for us um
another large part of um this revenue is
entry fees and entry fees again for the
most part was obviously the dip that
everybody experienced I think in the
last quarter of fiscal year 20 um April
through June but after that we sort of
saw our turn to normaly um so again that
has continued to do quite uh fairly well
for us um tring to think if there's any
other pieces here bail forfeitures it's
tough to say how people are going to
behave um obviously that's the people
who um pay bail and then don't show up
for their court hearing then they
forfeit the bail um fines have also um
they've gone down a little bit um as a
result of the pandemic so I'm seeing I
predicted a little bit of an uptick in
22 and held it steady in
23 so not a lot of change there and some
of the what we report is also default
fees collected by safety and those are
their figures um so and they've uh
continued to project a steady increase
um in 21 22 and
23 and so that's kind of that's most of
committee
representa hen
Phillips pH sorry thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to follow up Donna about
what you're saying and just see do you
have any overall impression about the
year toe decline in the number of cases
before the courts right now because of
covid um as opposed to other years when
you haven't had those Court um closures
Etc um I do not um that's not the kind
of data I usually get into I can
certainly look into that for you I my my
sense is you know ultimately people's
behavior hasn't changed all that much in
terms of how litigious they are I think
we saw you know there's a couple problem
at play here one is um just everybody
reacting initially to the pandemic in
those first three months the last
quarter of fiscal year 20 then we've had
you know some issues in terms of jury
trials right we've had to be very
mindful um of how many of those we can
conduct so my sense is there is stuff in
the pipeline that needs to get processed
I think people are the circuit court is
doing better in terms of how much of its
staff is out as a result of um you know
staff response to co either you know
being exposed themselves caring for
somebody that type of thing um that's
gotten a bit better over the last couple
of months and my hope is that as we get
warmer uh things will open up a little
bit air quality is a big issue with CO
as we're finding out now so I'm hoping
things will get a little bit better then
um we've been working with um an
epidemiologist to figure out how we keep
our courts um as safe as possible so um
there have been times when we've had to
cancel jury trials so again there's
backlog buil into that um but you know
I'm hoping that as we get better at this
um and also can conduct things remotely
we've done a big shift uh to be with
WebEx and things to be able to conduct
trials remotely but obviously um excuse
me to conduct hearings remotely but
obviously jury trials you can't quite do
that way so it doesn't solve everything
but we are you know working through this
to find Solutions um and hopefully we
will see some of that backlog resolve as
a result of it I think it would just be
an important correlation to draw if you
if you see a 5% docket decrease and
there's also a 5% fine decrease overall
right it would make complete sense but
right it's hard to know without having
that kind of background information
right like I said I can certainly ask to
see if we can get
that for the committee if if you go to
page 12 of the report that the Judiciary
gave us when they met with us on the
12th it has a break out of all the
components that make up the $12
million and the other that um Donna
talked about represents about 40% of
their total
contribution but page 12 of the document
that presented to us on the 26 will show
it
there you
okay we got the same kind of number on
page 13 but
uh you can on page 13 it reflects 21 22
and 23
correct and if you look at the other
fees on 20 20 you see those 6.1
million and the total to the highway is
13.3 so you're talking better than 40%
of that has to do with the other fees
and the other fees has all
those things that you refer to record
shacks and ENT Etc so rep of major if I
could just interject there you want to
take the subtotal line that's that is
the court fees that you're counting in
that unrestricted um Court's
bucket the penalty assessment on the
next line down
below that's included in the other
category the other Revenue
category so what Donna has shown you on
the sheet is the total unrestricted
Revenue that's sent over for the general
fund is this amount that I'm
highlighting right now but it's in two
different
buckets right so that this line is in
the court fees and fines bucket and the
assessment line is in the other fund
bucket right and then you go up above to
the other fee where
it's $6
million that's the bulk that's the
biggest yep
correct right yep and that's what Donna
started with yep
okay so there's a lot of things that
make
represent me
you I was just on it had been brought up
by someone I think that on the courts
are going to all electronic for record
searches at some point soon and the
question is whether you charge for that
the I think the person who talked
assumed that you didn't charge for the
record
searches um I don't know who else may
have spoken about it I know when I have
appeared before house Ways and Means
over the last several years I have
always brought it up just as to keep it
uh in the back of your minds I have not
heard anything uh recently about this
becoming um public record search and
therefore free of charge um like I said
that 6 point you know three or four
million about 65 to 75% of that is
records research fee so it is a sizable
chunk of that amount of money so I I
only bring it up um in case something
does happen where um that does become uh
free of charge that would represent you
know around a four four and a half
million dollar reduction to the revenues
that we would take in but as I said I
[Music]
progressing so we have to watch what we
do that's
right we want to do those things but
yeah cause and an effect right
right all right any other questions for
for
Donna I don't see any hands raises so
thank you Donna for coming in and going
over this with us great thank you very
have that's all you had scheduled for
today reps of major
okay so
tomorrow we'll start at 9:00 of liquor
and then go on to Insurance Securities
Lottery fishing game and
other and then we'll be through the
revenues for for this for the time
being this is just so that you can ask
questions about the very things that
affect the
revenues repr major I just want to
comment make one quick comment actually
two quick comments
um the Statewide property tax revenue
which is generally accounted for by uh
Dr wasn't something they spoke with you
about that set statutorily to be um 3
363 million. one you sometimes get
3632 depending on how the the um
calculation goes for valuation but
that's the statutory limit so that
wasn't discussed and I don't think that
there's really a debate unless there's
going to be a change to the statute that
drives that um that the Statewide
property tax so that's why they didn't
talk about it and I just but I just want
the committee to know it's on the
schedule it's on the worksheet as one of
your Revenue sources the other is the
tobacco um settlement I did not invite
um the Attorney General back to discuss
that I think he was pretty clear in what
he discussed the other day today that he
really doesn't have anything to add
until sometime in April um when he sees
what they're going to get for this
year's uh settlement amount and then
possibly what impacts might be occurring
sense all right any questions from the
committee before
we Mr chairman do you have on an a date
that we're going to be uh trying to put
numbers
these
um I have an estimate but
it's I need to talk sit down and talk
with both you and
Pat about how we want to proceed on that
we still have some questions that we
like brought up today we need to
bring uh somebody into better so we
better understand
the co
situation
and what
can or can't or could
happen and we need to take into account
as we do our estimates because that Co
revenues
and I feel it's important to get that
information before we finish that but we
need to uh
we in a good position by the 16th of
this month which isn't too far
away as I I want to be in a good
position before we meet with the
18th so
that we
can ask very intelligent questions of
him
of why and see if his Revenue estimates
are anywhere near
what our draft Revenue estimates are at
time thank you I think we have a blank
week we will be having work
sessions and thank
you I need to get a schedule out by
tomorrow
time we do know that on this we have
this Thursday we have full day of public
hearings we have full days of public
hearings of wak from
Thursday and on the 17th we have a full
day of public hearing we need to have an
exact
session especially to get the early bill
out I hope to maybe this Thursday we can
do
is I can't remember the the number on it
it's representative of bram's liquor
bill right we want to get that out next
uh maybe we can get it out this
Thursday because
uh we say that executive sessions may
follow on each day that we have public
hearings so we have three more days of
public hearing schedule 4th the 11th and
the
17th the 18th will meet with the
govern's budget direct dat so now in
between that
we have work
sessions do so and then we also have to
meet this committee as a
whole on bills thater
that uh we need to work on and also as a
committee as a
whole agree on those bills that we don't
need any more information we can either
ought to pass as is or
itl or op to pass as amended
or the amount of work needed we don't
have sufficient time we we have to
retained so we need to have time to do
those so um knowing all this I have
review everybody should be reviewing the
bills that we already heard and those
that we haven't heard so that when we do
have the public hearing they ask the
right type of
questions so representative Tucker yes
uh I thought today's been a really good
day and I it occurred to me that really
it's a lot easier to hear when we're all
on Zoom from our home offices than it is
the hybrid which because of the
microphones turned out to be hard for us
at home to hear those of you who were in
the hearing room and um I just wanted to
comment that maybe the microphones could
be adjusted in the hearing rooms or
maybe we should
reconsider whether zooming from home
isn't really easier for everybody to
hear you know what um that's on my mind
uh talk to the speaker that if uh
actually Aaron who's the chief of staff
I says if you can't fix those
microphones and we should really do our
public
hearings
by
virtual
yes be nice for you to have the feedback
as to those of at home how we're we're
perceiving it that's what say I don't
mind a bit not having a two-hour Drive
each way to him is
that what effect is the public hearing
people can't hear
people it's it's a waste and so uh what
I was veering to is is holding a public
hearings virtually now today they had to
hold the public hearing
and that's a good excuse to continuing
it so I'm I'm I'm working on that well
thank you very
much Norm when you Norm yes one option
is to actually everybody who shows if
they want to be there in person bring
your laptop with
you and and use that and and turn off
the microphones other than the one that
we use on the table for the people to
it's rare that someone's going to
testify uh in person um other than a rep
that's around they're the only ones that
can testify turn up the microphones
because the problem we had was that it
was
feedback I had my I had my laptop turned
on and it was too close to a microphone
and was getting feedback so if we turn
off the microphones and just all use our
laptops then you could say well why do
we even go there uh it was just a
camaraderie for those of us who were
there I kind of enjoyed the fact that I
I met some couple of the new members
we had a chance to
chat um I mean other than that I I tend
to agree you know we could probably
accomplish this without without going
there physically but uh I did enjoy I
enjoyed the com comaraderie in between
things thank you I agree with you but if
people can't hear they can't understand
and it's a
waste no I'm agreeing with you Norm but
it's it's uh U I think I think one one
way we can hit handle this is if you're
going to show up use your laptop turn
off the
microphones so that so that there's no
feedback um is is what I'm suggesting
and maybe you could talk to Aon well
we'll talk offline about this right and
it's very and it's also difficult some
people have desktops they don't have
laptops I'm one of
those I don't have also some some of us
with laptops don't have enough battery
power that we could survive the meeting
I I you know what I did repres Ami I
brought my own extension cord and U and
strip and plugged
in there's actually they they did
provide some additional uh extension
cords for this St because there's only a
couple outlets in the in the room and I
heavy that I couldn't bring it and and
trying to conduct a meeting with an iPad
very small it's not
easy well anyway I just thought I'd
bring it up be I thought you'd like
hearing the feedback and think a public
hearing it's nice to be able to hear I
think tonight I'll I'll hear how well
today went for those that had to conduct
all their meetings virtually
today and and see how that
did but you're right it would be nice if
we could meet but I've got SLS of
grandchildren great grandchildren I
can't even see them
anymore or neighbors and friends and
so uh anything
else oh if
I my wife interrupted me this morning to
let me know
that at 1:10 tomorrow if I show up at a
certain place we can get our first
shots so tomorrow it's only scheduled
for the morning so I should have any
problem getting my first shot of the
virus you are lucky with the vaccine on
I haven't got
mine I was scheduled for the 18th but
uh
I had to throw that out than you
jealous I think representative gorg had
a
question uh representative G it wasn't
so much a question just a comment to
representative um well so the multiple
laptop in a room actually um will do
feedback as well so when you hear the
echo when that means somebody has
multiple um audio so if you're sitting
next to somebody who also has Zoom
you're gonna have an echo so just keep
that in the back of your minds if you as
iners it's not
easy conduct
Co let me find out tonight how well the
hearings went today
and don't be surprised if we change this
into compl virtual on Thursday we'll
have today to to I mean tomorrow to war